- Question for you, Connor,
have you noticed that
since you moved to Japan
you just start bowing for everything?
- No, but you know what I do do?
I do one of anime reaction noises.
- No, I do the same thing as well.
- And you put a thing, what the fuck?
That's weird as fuck, Connor.
Why would you do that?
- Like a, yeah.
- Yeah, okay this is why I
make so much sense now, right?
'Cause whenever they ask me
for like anything at the supermarket
I'm like caught off guard, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
It makes total sense while
I do it in anime now.
- No, because I've noticed
when Japanese people
when you're talking to them
they need to make it known
that they're listening.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- In England, people kind of
just stand there or just nod.
Japanese like hi, hi.
And I've started doing
the same thing as well.
Whenever someone is talking
I'm always having to make it known that-
- I do that in interviews and people like,
"Can't you just shut up for five seconds?
And just let the other person talk?"
But I have to.
- Oh my God.
Damn.
- Oh yeah, I guess we're
putting that at the beginning.
- And that's the intro,
go and take it away, Joey.
- Take it away.
(soft music)
- What's up you naughty Neanderthals.
Welcome back to another
episode of Trash Taste podcast.
I am not gonna stop doing this.
- How long were you sitting on that for?
Was that like-
- Like two seconds.
(laughing)
- I bet you have a fucking script
or just go through the alphabet.
- Excel sheet.
- Exactly, I'm like I have to
make an alliteration somehow.
So let's just pick a letter
and just roll with it.
Well, welcome to Trash Taste,
the show where we talk
about a trash taste and
everything else in the world.
I'm your host for today, Joey,
And as always I'm with Garnt and Connor.
- We were doing this now.
We're probably doing this.
- Yeah, I know.
So, this episode I thought we would
maybe talk about something,
I don't know if it's gonna
get a little too personal.
We'll try not to go too personal route,
but to go back to the whole thing
about how we first started
talking about anime
and how we got into anime.
We've already done that episode on that.
- Yeah, we've already
done our origin story.
- But how did we meet?
Or how did we make our first,
I don't know how to say it, anime friend?
Is that a thing?
- I don't know.
Okay, so I have a question for you guys.
Okay, to start this off
because we talked about
our anime origin story
like how we got into anime,
but when you guys were anime fans,
did you have any friends
in school or anything?
Or how did you guys deal with that?
'Cause I was a cluster anime fan.
- Yeah.
- I was a complete cluster anime fan.
- For all of school?
- Yes.
- I think that's a British thing though.
Like I got rinsed for playing video games.
So imagine if I came
out and was like this.
I like this,
- I like anime too.
- This is my new thing now.
- It like those drawn.
- Yeah, can you believe I got mocked
for playing video games in school?
And now it's just like
the accepted past time.
I got so much shit for that.
- That's weird because in my school,
video games were quite normalized.
Or was it just your school maybe?
- Did you?
- No, no, I got rinsed
in my school as well.
- Really?
- Unless you're playing FIFA or chords-
- Which I was and I still got rinsed.
- What?
- I would be sitting in
my room in university
playing some GRPG hoping
that nobody opens the door
to discover the fact
that I was playing GRPG
not any other kind of a game.
- I think if I come out saying that
I was a massive GRPG fan where I was you
playing Persona 3 or something.
Then I probably would've
gotten beaten up as well, but-
- I got so much shit
for playing RuneScape.
And I still, to this day-
- Really?
- I think I love RuneScape.
I remember some videos pop
up in my recommended recently
and I had a great time watching them.
- Because in my school,
I think my group of friends,
we were more so than not
I guess like the nerdy group of friends.
- Yeah, I was too, I was too.
- So a lot of my friends from high school
got means a games like
RuneScape, like Star Croft.
other just like land
games, like Civilization,
those games back in the day.
But when it came to anime,
I think I had a really tough time
because I was literally the
only Asian kid in my school.
- Oh no, same to me.
I was the only Asian kid in my school.
- With like any amount of Asian blood.
Like I'm not even like full-blood Asian.
But they just like,
"Oh, this boy's a little bit oriental."
(laughing)
- He's nice?
What the hell?
Yeah, so I think I was
a closet anime fan for,
man, I wanna say like majority
of my high school life
but then my group of friends who got me
into like Star Croft and
Rune Scape I was like,
"Okay, you guys are nerdy enough.
"Maybe I can try and convince
them to watch something."
And I convinced one of
my friends to watch Ava.
So I was like-
- Why Ava?
That's not already the gateway
anime I will think off.
- I don't know.
Maybe because I was
recently rewatching Ava.
And I thought,
"Okay, this is probably normie enough."
- No.
- That they can be maybe get into it.
- Recommending Ava as
someone's first anime.
That could go one of two ways.
- Yeah.
- There's gonna be no middle grounds
either he's gonna think this is amazing.
And he's a fan for life.
- But the thing is I
didn't want to get them
into like Natto or One
piece or Dragon Ball
to start with because we all know
if your to gateway anime
is One Piece, Natto
or Dragon Ball.
That's all you're gonna be talking about
for the rest of your career so-
- Hey man, I don't know man.
I mean, I got in for Natto,
but I mean I remember the point when-
- You got out.
You got out.
- I got out, I got out.
There was the point when
I would only watch Shounen
and I know the exact phase
you're talking about.
And then you figure out
that there's other things
outside of Shounen that are
pretty cool in this medium.
And some people, I guess
just never figured that out.
- I feel like Natto fans,
I like the British with food.
It's like, no, no, no
potatoes is all we need.
(laughing)
Spice what is-
- What is it about like
it's not obviously not all
Shounen fans, but a lot
of Shounen fans who are
as you said, like get into say, Natto,
and then just exclusively
talking about Natto.
What is it...
I wanna know what their
mentality is with anime
where it's like,
do they just think that
everything that's not Natto,
it's just anti?
(laughing)
There's like, no, no, no,
there's no in between.
It's either Shounen or just
like straight up R18 and shit.
- They're like, what is this
high school romance shit?
I don't wanna feel.
I wanna feel one emotion and that's hype.
- Show Jo, is that a type of Shounen?
- It must be the thing of like,
"I get it.
It's hype as fuck."
But they just must want
hype their whole life,
- Yeah, your like a crack addict, right?
- Yeah.
- You only wanna feel that
high you get from crack.
- It's like steroids.
- There're the same
people and you're like,
"Yo, E3 is crazy this year."
(laughing)
- Every game, every game.
I'm hyped for every game
and then they don't play any of them.
They like the next Modern Warfare.
- Yeah, but in the moment there's
a bad news article about the game
that just came out in E3 and they're like,
"Yeah, I knew it was shit.
"The whole time.
"The whole time."
Yeah, no.
So like my anime friend, so
there was a group of them.
It was like me and maybe like,
I'd say like six or
seven guys who I used to
really, really, closely hang
out with in high school.
And I got, one of my friends who got me
into like Star Croft.
I got him to watch Ava
and I wanted to try that
just with one person
I didn't I wanna like bring in
a whole group of people into it.
- It's group viewing.
- So I kind of was just
like eeny, meeny, miny, moe,
okay, I add you watch Ava and he was like,
"Okay, I'll give it a go."
And he was kind of mad about it at first.
- Yeah.
- I liked anime and I was
like at points kind of like,
"What the fuck."
- And that was the Memorial was like,
"Oh, gateway anime important."
(laughing)
- And Ava is not bad.
- Always Death Note, you can
never go wrong with Death Note.
- Yeah so I think that
one friend he watched Ava
and then he eventually found
Death Note and Onepiece
and those like the two shows
that he heavily gone into.
So he was like,
"Okay then maybe I can try
it out with the other boys.
"Hey, watch Death Note, watch Onepiece.
(laughing)
- There was boys before us?
Joey, what do you mean?
- This were the OG boys.
- Do you know what the
name of that like...
This is gonna be really cringy but...
We had like a group.
- What was the name Joey?
- It was the...
(laughing)
We were called HBK because we were...
Did you guys ever play handball in school?
- No.
- I think that's an Australian thing.
So in Australian schools we play handball
but not like the Olympic sport handball
like school grounds handball
but usually most kids in
Australia stop playing handball
by around like sixth grade.
- So its very rare that
you going to middle school
or high school and play handball.
We played handball all the way
until high school graduation.
And we were the only ones.
And so from no where we were called HBK,
which is the Hand Ball Krew.
(laughing)
- Krew with a K?
- Krew with a K.
- Of course
- And it was just out of nowhere.
One day just the other boys in our year
just saw us playing hand
ball and they were like,
"HBK."
And we're like,
"What the fuck?
"What the fuck does that mean?"
And then we later found
out it meant handball krew
and normal people would be like,
"Oh, that's fucking cringy."
And we were like,
"Handball Krew."
(laughing)
Hell yeah.
- I think handball is something I've only
heard Australians play in their school
'cause obviously you've seen
handball in the Olympics
and everything like that.
- When we had like a British team
like when did they play that?
- I know right.
- But it's completely
different to the Olympic sport.
So when I saw handball,
'cause I'd always known
handball as that thing
that you play in school,
where it's like four white squares
and you kind of like-
- Yeah.
- It's basically just
tennis but with your hand
and a tennis ball in a
really confined space.
So when I saw handball in
the Olympic sport I was like,
"What the fuck is this?
"This isn't handball."
- It's really interesting to
hear you say going back to the
anime conversation that we were having
because I didn't even make
my first anime friends,
till I started YouTube.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Really?
- That was years after I started YouTube.
- Oh, wow.
- So I didn't start
talking to other people
who liked anime until
the age of the internet.
Well, I literally started
talking to other people
who reviewed anime because
back when I was in school
and especially when I was in university
I did everything I could
to keep it under wraps.
(laughing)
- Even in uni?
- Even in uni.
- Really?
- It was like top secret confidential.
If you find this out,
I'm gonna change my identity
or something like that.
- I remember someone walked
into my room of me watching
No game No life in university.
And it was the moment of like,
"How do I explain what's going on here?"
It was one of the bad scenes as well.
I'm like...
- I have a really similar story.
So in uni first year of university
in England at least we have
this thing called freshers week.
Where you basically go out
every night and get pissed-
- Very, very drunk.
- Get very, very drunk
and just go clubbing.
- It sounds awesome.
- Yeah, so me being the
socially awkward nerd that I was back then
I would still try to go
out as much as I could,
but I mean it can get tiring,
six or seven days of just
pure clubbing every day
man that shit gets to you.
- Yeah, that's a lot man.
I don't know how people do it.
And then people would like look
forward to it the next year.
- I know.
- And I'm like-
- I don't know how,
I feel 30 already in this
one week of freshers.
So this one night I was just in a club
and I wasn't even that drunk.
Cause I'd been drinking five
or six days before that.
I was just in the middle
of this dance floor.
And I just had like this epiphany,
"I'm having a shit time.
"I'd probably rather be watching...
"I'd rather be watching anime right now."
Like I was just that one guy
who just dances in a club
and just had the, this is shit.
(laughing)
- Especially every time I
go to the club, I'm like,
"I need more drinks."
- So instead of getting
more drinks, I'm just like,
"I'm gonna fuck off and go home
"and watch some bloody anime."
And I didn't tell anyone that
I was fucking off back home.
So I go of by myself-
- You're that guy in uni.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I'm the lone wolf don't talk to me.
- I just wanted to watch some anime.
And what the fuck am I doing in a club
when I could be watching
some big fat animated
which is exactly what I did.
- You got that on a T-shirt.
- I go back to my room
and as you do in uni you're...
Unlike Americans in England
we have own private rooms
so we don't room share.
- The thought of having to
share rooms with with someone
I'd go fucking insane.
- Yeah, exactly.
So I have this remote to myself
and as you do I take off my
trousers because as a guy
you're just more
comfortable in your boxers.
- It's true, the jeans
are too restrictive.
- Jeans are way too restrictive.
So take off my trousers,
start sitting down,
turn on my laptop and put on
the episode of Monogatari and-
- The toothbrush scene is it gonna be?
- No, no it was the shower
scene with Senjougahara.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So it was like episode two
and I was really getting into this.
- Wait, what do you
mean getting into this?
(laughing)
Its Monogatari, its a good series.
- Its a good scene.
- How sober are you at this point?
Like I fully sober?
- I was like a little-
- Like that point you feel shitty, like?
- I was like a little bit tipsy,
but I was just having a good
time because you know when
you haven't watched anime in a while
and it just feels good to watch anime
after that anime drought, that was just,
"Oh, man, this is just a
nice break from all the
"drinking and clubbing and
socializing and all that stuff."
And as soon as it gets
to the shower scene,
I just hear this door creak open like,
(laughing)
and then I look around and
then one of my flatmates
is just staring at me and I turn round
and it's just me and my boxers watching.
And all he sees is just
Senjougahara massive tits
on screen taking a shower.
And I try to eye him up to be like,
"This isn't what it looks like."
And he eyes me back saying,
"Oh, shit this is exactly
what it looks like."
(laughing)
- You should have asserted dominance just
to maintain eye contact.
- And then he just closes
the door and I'm just like,
"Okay, I'm moving to China now.
"He knows my secrets."
And then he just never spoke to me again.
- I have a way worse story than that.
It was again like during high school,
when I had gotten like the one friend
that I got him into Ava.
So he unlike everybody else,
like everybody kind of got into anime.
I was closeted for a while
but I kind of was like,
"I needed to get out of the closet."
(laughing)
I need to try and convince my friends
that this is an okay thing to watch.
So you need to make a
YouTube video saying,
I'm coming out.
- Yeah, I'm coming out.
I like anime.
- You're exactly right.
- So the one friend, the
guy I first experimented on.
(laughing)
- Why are you gotta use this
terminology Joey to explain?
- Because I was experimenting.
- You're just like Light Yagami being
funny every step being like,
"Okay, If I show them this
anime maybe they'll like."
- It's like maybe one of
them will like get into it.
And sure enough, one of them got into it.
So I was just like,
"Kick off with Doughty."
(laughing)
So he, just my one friend, he
really, really got into anime.
I'm talking like, him and I
would come to school every week
and we would discuss the
episodes that just came out
like the night before.
Like him and I were like
full on like anime buddies.
And one night we were
drinking at a friend's place.
And, obviously as you do
when you're in high school,
you get really shit faced, right?
- Of course.
- And I was staying at his place
and I had missed the bus home
and everything so I was like,
"All right, I'm just
gonna crash at yours."
And it was just him and
I, and we were like,
"we should watch some anime, why not?
"Lets just watch some anime."
And I don't know how it came to it but
we were just kind of scrolling through
just looking for something
to watch and he's like,
"You watched this no,
"you've watched this no."
And I just kind of slowly turned to him,
just as a gag goes like,
"You ever heard of QC's?
(laughing)
- Oh no.
- He's like,
"No, what's that?"
And I'm like,
"We should check it out.
"We'll just watch one episode
just for shits and giggles.
"Let's watch an episode of QC's."
So imagine me and my
friend sitting in a room,
six feet apart because we
are not gay, just watching...
- Just bonding over an episode of QC.
- It just sound like every incest moment
happened to like porn.
- And it was worse
because I dunno how long
he was standing at the
door but his little brother
(laughing)
was standing at the door just watching us,
watch QC and we were like into it too.
We all like,
"Oh, hell yeah."
(laughing)
- This kids are like Michael Jackson like-
- Mind you we were very drunk.
We were like,
"Who's your favorite?"
And he's like,
"Oh man, they're both really cute."
Just full on like, you
would've thought we were
like making a reaction video.
We weren't like full on
commentating the entire thing.
- Oh my God.
- And what was supposed to
be just for shit and giggles.
Just one episode of QC we finished
the entire series in one night.
- What?
- Yeah.
- Oh my God.
Did he enjoy it?
- He loved it.
(laughing)
- And that was the
moment where I was like,
"This guy's a (indistinct)."
- Don't go home with Joey drunk
he'll try and show you shitty anime.
- Yeah, I've done that.
- I like the fact that
you had to wait until he was alone.
(laughing)
- Yeah because, this other
boys were like discussing
how good the Alabaster Arc
in Onepiece was and I'm like,
"I don't think these
boys are ready QC's yet."
These guys are at level one thief
and this guys are level 10 mafia boss.
So I was like,
"Let's experiment with y'all mafia boys."
- Joey is like the sensei
who sees the hidden potential
in that one student he's like,
"I can teach you the way."
- I sense it in you.
- Yeah, you're ready to learn.
You're ready to upgrade.
- So did he enjoy more of
that kind of show afterwards?
- So then that was the
point where we basically
Him and I, we found out
from each other that
we're into those kinds of
shows and we're okay with it.
(laughing)
- We're just into each other.
- We were just into those kinds of shows.
'Cause after we finished
QC we're both just like,
"I just gotta let you
know broad now that we've
"had this fucking like
journey together that
"I'm like secretly into these shows."
(laughing)
Every single moment of this story you tell
could be like a coming out to each other.
- And he was like dude,
"I'm kind of into these shows."
And then from there-
- Are you doing this on purpose?
(laughing)
Dude I'm kind of into you.
- Mike just had enough.
- Mike's like,
"I gotta get the fuck out."
And yeah, so from that point on,
I became a lot more open with
my trashy taste in anime, right?
- Joey is like,
"Yes, I'm hentia sexual."
- Are you purposely
picking words to do this?
- No, no.
- Then stop this.
- I am writing.
Look, y'all re write this,
this is free real estate.
All right, go for it.
But yeah, but that was the
point where I slowly realized,
if I'm closeted then I'll
obviously have a lot of fun
just kind of enjoying
this medium for myself.
But there's a whole other enjoyment
when you get someone else into it as well.
- I remember the first time I
was able to have conversations
about anime with other people.
And that was just so
liberating for me that
I had spent all of these
years enjoying this medium
but have literally
nobody to talk to about.
And then I made YouTube videos to be like,
"Okay if I can't have
anyone to talk to about
"I'm just gonna talk to the void
"and hopefully someone will listen."
And I remember having some of the first
genuine conversations online
'cause it had to be online back then
about shows that I liked
and I just felt free.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- 'Cause I don't know
who your first friends
in like the anime YouTube sphere was?
For me it was probably Holden reviews
and the people from PODTAKU
we going and going way back then.
- I think mine might've been Misty,
- Yours is Misty?
- I think.
- I mean, except for the one in jail,
I don't think there's anyone else
I would categorize like...
A lot of them were just
like fleeting mutuals.
I'll tell you guys probably
the first proper friends
that I made outside of that first-
- Yeah because it was
strange for me because
I'm the complete opposite when it comes to
my friends circle on YouTube,
where you would think
that I would be very quick
to bond with other animetubers,
the one's starting anime YouTube channel.
But weirdly enough for like
the first two years or so,
I was only friends with gaming YouTubers
but that's also because I was doing
a lot of gaming stuff
alongside anime stuff.
And I think it honestly
might've been misty.
That was the first like proper animetuber.
And that was when I discovered
this entire community
of animetubers I was like,
"Oh my God, I'm not the only one.
"There are other people
who do this stuff as well."
And then that's when I
kind of to drift away
from more of the gaming stuff
and focus on what my
channel was actually about.
- Yeah.
- I remember I realized
we had comments sometimes
that are like me listening
to the podcast and it's like,
"That guy sitting next to."
(laughing)
- I love that feature.
I love that anime, its so good.
- 'Cause I remember I
was doing my A levels.
I remember listening to PodTaku actually,
I remember I used to listened to it.
Yeah, I would do my...
I remember I have this distinct memory
of you guys arguing.
I don't know over what,
but I was doing my-
- We argue over a lot of things.
- Yeah, I was doing my math A levels,
I was, and I remember
just listening to it.
And I was like,
"Man, and I wanna like be in that.
"Talk to them."
- I wanna have friends, man.
- I wanna like talk to friends about anime
even at that point when I was like,
what, like 17, I still had no
one to talk to about anime.
- Yeah.
- And I didn't really make
friends until university
but I got banned from my
anime club Facebook group.
'Cause they were talking
about like Hellsing Abridged.
And I was like,
"Shit, I've voiced in that."
I said in the comments, I was like,
"Oh, yeah, I voiced in it."
And then they banned me.
(laughing)
They thought I was lying.
Because they were like,
why would someone in our
university first year
be voicing in Hellsing Abridged.
And then I went to the
club and I explained,
like two months later I went,
- Yeah.
- I happened to go there anyway.
And I was like,
"Yeah, can you unban me from the club?
"I don't know why you guys ban me."
And they're like,
"Well, we don't know."
I'm like,
"I know you fucking
know why you banned me."
- We couldn't have someone having clouts.
- I was in that group for like a year.
And I had one comment about that.
I got immediately banned.
Fuck you, Swansea Anime Club.
- They were just waiting for,
a fucking ban have on that murmur.
- They were like,
"Nope, no clout in this club."
- Yeah, yeah.
- My God.
- So you joined the anime
club in your university then?
- I joined, I paid the two
pound a year membership
and then all they did
was watch Gigli movies
and that's all they did
and I'm like, this is-
- I joined the anime club in my university
it was the biggest mistake ever.
- Its like, its weird.
'Cause it's like a mixture of like...
It's a mixture of people who
don't really care about anime
and like one or two people
who are way too into it
or into really different niches.
So I felt like, I don't know.
I couldn't really talk with...
None of them watched the same I watched.
- Yeah.
- And it was the same with gaming.
The gaming club in my uni
was supposed to be gaming
and it was Orchard Magic, The Gathering.
(laughing)
- I mean it's type of gaming.
- It's type of game, but
you think of gaming club.
- Yeah, then diversify a little bit.
- Yeah, yeah and I was like,
'Well, guess I'm not
joining any clubs in unis.
"Brony Club it is.
- Oh, go for it.
- I was gonna say, I made a
whole video on it a while ago,
but I joined the anime club.
There was one anime club at Sydney Uni
and I joined it and I went
to one of their events.
Just one, and it was a screening
and it was off Paprika.
I was like, okay, it's a screening.
And it's all the non Ghibli movie.
Okay, whoever's picking it must know-
- They have taste.
They know something
outside of just, right?
- I know.
I was like, okay.
And I wanted to watch Paprika
'cause I hadn't seen it yet.
And so I went to it and
the club wasn't that big.
It was maybe I'd say
40 people in this room.
Which is quite small club
for, especially Sydney Uni.
And I was like,
"Okay, these people all seem
to be excited about this.
"Maybe let's watch it."
And this is the one thing
I hate about anime clubs.
And also this is the one thing I hate
about cinemas in the U.S
is that they love to fucking commentate
on what's happening in the movie out loud.
- I cannot stand that.
- I can't stand, especially U.S cinemas.
It's something that U.S
cinemas where it's like,
if there's like a big epic, right?
Like say you go watch fucking
Avengers or something, right?
And something massive
happens or some whatever.
There's always like at
least 10 or 20 people
who were just like, yeah...
And they just go off about like...
They give like they're like
fucking Rotten Tomatoes
with you on the spot, right?
- I feel like I'm 80 years old
whenever I'm one of those screens.
'Cause I'm just like,
"Quiet down.
"I'm trying to enjoy the film."
I'm like, can you shhh, shut the fuck up.
"I'm trying to watch the movie."
- That's like special occasions,
where it's kind of warranted,
like watching End Game.
All right, I get it.
You can shout.
I watch Chromat AIX, insane.
The hype made it amazing.
The worst thing was,
one of my exes I went to the cinema with,
they've never watched a
movie in the cinema before
and I was like,
"All right, cool."
And then she was one of those people.
Didn't know that?
How do you know that?
That's not like on a Tinder bio, right?
(laughing)
And then she shouted during
the first five minutes.
And I was like,
"Okay."
In my head I'm thinking,
"All right, let's not make
this a reoccurring thing."
And then like two minutes
later, she shouts again.
And I'm like,
"Please, please don't do this, please.
"I'm British, you can't do this.
"I can't be seen with you
"if you're making a commotion in public."
- Yeah.
And then that's how I realized
that she wasn't right for me.
- That's why I liked Japanese cinemas, man
because like it's-
- No.
Okay.
Okay, go ahead, go ahead, sorry.
- Oh, no, no.
I know how you feel
about Japanese cinemas,
- Right.
- There's a part of it that I like.
And there's a part of
it that I don't like.
The part that I like about it
is that people aren't fucking shouting
there rotten tomatoes
reviews during the movie.
- No one says anything.
- No one says anything but-
- I liked that.
- Yeah, I like that too.
'Cause especially if it's a movie
that you need to immerse yourself in,
like fucking Paprika, for instance,
it's like I want it to be just quiet
and I wanna get into it.
But the bad thing is that
I went to go see the corner Super Movie.
Which is easily one of
the funniest anime movies
I've ever seen.
But I felt really bad laughing out loud
because I was literally the only person
laughing out loud in the cinema.
And every time I was like,
(laughing)
- Oh, shit.
- I don't think that's
was supposed to be funny.
- Did anybody else find that funny?
- I've had similar
experiences in a time movies
or going into time cinemas
where I remember watching
Yuni cinemas.
And I don't know if it's
just a cultural difference
but there would be times
when they were laughing
and I would be like,
"Why is this funny?"
And there'd be a really funny joke.
And then I'd be the only guy laughing.
And I'm like,
"Am I the asshole here?
Do I just have a really
weird sense of humor."
- I know, I felt so
bad because I was like,
"Is anyone genuinely not
finding this movie funny?
"Am I the only one?"
Yeah, I hated it.
- I've been going to the
cinema at least before COVID.
I was going like pretty much every week.
And like there's some of
the things they do great.
I showed you guys this in the cinema.
- Yeah.
- When you buy popcorn and the drink
they give you this tray.
And you're like,
"Oh that's cool."
And then you realize
you can put it in the
cup holder and it sticks.
So you have a whole tray
that's in the cup holder.
It's fucking genius.
- Yeah.
- No one would have to hold this shit.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You just put it on the tray.
- You don't have to put
fucking greasy thing on your lap.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Put your popcorn on your tray
and the person next to
you can have it, whatever.
Amazing, right?
Amazing.
And then the thing that I hate...
Also, yeah, no noise.
The only time I've ever
seen them make noise
in a Japanese cinema,
I was watching the movie
and it was about a bomb
that was gonna go off in
one of the Olympics, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- And this police officers accused...
Anyway, they go to his
house to search his house
and they ask him, do you have any guns?
He's like,
"Yeah, I have guns."
And he shows his, under his mattress
and he has like a 100 guns
and the whole cinema goes,
(laughing)
Every Japanese was like-
- Meanwhile, if they show
them in the US cinema,
there's like-
- Second Amendment.
- Yeah.
- Weak sauce.
- I realized I said the wrong amendment.
(laughing)
And then also one really
annoying thing, right?
When the movie ends,
the credits come.
All right, see you guys, I'm off,
Japanese cinemas you cannot leave.
- No.
- Until the credits are over.
- Yeah.
- And some of these credits go on
for like 20 fucking minutes.
And I'm like the first few
times I was like, you know what?
I'll respect the culture, I'll wait.
Now I'm just like,
"Credits?
"I'm going, fuck you guys.
"I'm avoiding credits."
- Caveman brain activates again.
- I don't care about the seven people
that did costume design.
I'm sorry.
I'm not sticking around for that long.
- And then I'm the asshole
who in front of a 100 thing is like,
"All right, see you guys."
I'm just walking,
I don't give a fuck.
I'm not waiting 30 minutes-
- Yeah, I found that aspect to be cool.
Because obviously the
people go to the cinemas,
they respect them.
I wanna know who did.
And who worked on this movie?
But as you said,
I think the Japanese like
film industry is aware
that people have to stick
around to the credits
so they're like,
"How do we extend this as long as we can?"
Its like in YouTube,
we're trying to extend a
video 10 minutes, right?
(laughing)
- Its like,
"How do we extend this
credit to 10 minutes
"to get that mid rolling?"
- I don't dunno like, I
used to be the same where
I would think,
why the would anyone stay
when the credits rolling?
I don't give a shit about this.
And then I remember
I did it once for a movie
that just blew me away.
I think...
I can't remember the exact name.
- Paul Block.
(laughing)
- But I remember most recently I did it
after watching Your
Name and A Silent Voice.
And it's actually just
a really nice feeling
to just to absorb
everything you just watch
and just sit there in silence.
I don't know, when a-
- Sometimes, I'm gonna go there.
- When a movie hits really deep,
I can't...
"We're doing this again,
we're doing this again."
- Oh my God.
- But when a movie affects me that way
(laughing)
- He got it.
He got it, buddy.
He got it.
- Then it's just nice
just to absorb everything
you just watch instead of just being like,
"All right, boys.
"I'm off, I'm off.
"We'd be good."
I go.
(laughing)
- That's good, that's good.
- Yeah, that's the one thing I appreciate
about some film credits, right?
If it's like, I really enjoy watching,
the toy story credits
because they do the behind
the scenes bloopers real shit.
That shit's fucking cool.
But when it's a black screen
and just white text
scrolling for 10 minutes-
- Which often is.
Then I'm just like, I mean you guys know
we have to stick around for the credits.
Can you at least make it
entertaining in some fashion?
And even isn't it the worst?
Well, when the credit song is just like,
I'm not digging this credits at all.
And I have to sit here and
listen to the whole goddamn song.
- I was too lazy for that.
I just leave and then I watch
the after scene credit on YouTube.
'Cause it's gonna be on YouTube.
- But you can use the
gauging, Connor, right?
- Yeah, I mean, I normally catch,
sometimes when I do it
the Japanese were like,
"Well, we can do that?"
(laughing)
And then they'll get up too.
- Follow the white man.
(laughing)
- Whoa, whoa, wait, wait, wait, wait.
No one is stopping me here.
- I don't wanna-
- "He just cheating the system.
"I never thought you could do that."
- When I do it, I notice
I'll get a few looks,
and then I'll be like,
two of the people who
stand up and go as well.
I'm like,
"Yeah, join me.
"Join me."
(laughing)
It is freedom.
- It's like the trust
isn't that Japan runs on,
like buying alcohol.
- I'm slowly breaking that trust system.
I don't know.
The more, I don't know,
I'd say the older I get,
the more I have less time
the more I just don't
appreciate the waste of my time.
And I'm just like,
"Nope, I'm not waiting for your credits.
"Goodbye."
- Yeah.
So speaking of Gaijin combo,
have you guys ever used the Gaijin card,
in like funny situations?
Should we explain what the Gaijin card is?
- Sure, you should probably-
- Go for it, Joey.
- Go for it.
- I mean, I'm sure everyone
knows what the Gaijin card is.
But basically the Gaijin card,
is Gaijin means foreigner in Japanese
but playing the Gaijin
card basically means
you get away with shit
that Japanese people
wouldn't be able to
get away with in Japan.
But they forgive you
because you're supposed to
be like a mindless foreigner.
- I mean, I try not to
actively take advantage of it.
'Cause I feel like it's
not fair of me to use
being a foreigner 'cause everyone
goes through the same struggles, right?
That's hard enough.
But I mean, there's some stuff like,
apparently not supposed to
eat and walk here, right?
- Yeah.
- I do that.
- If I have like 10
minutes to get to my train
and I haven't had breakfast,
I'm grabbing that sandwich and eating it.
I don't throw my shit away.
I don't make a mess.
So I'm like, it's fine.
- I always wonder that,
why is it that a lot of
convenience store food
is so perfectly packaged for on the go.
- Right, right, right, right, right.
- And it's like, but you
can't eat on the go though.
- Like Onigira, that's
basically a rice sandwich.
- Yeah.
- That's meant to be eaten
as you're walking along, but,
"No, you can't while you walk."
- No one gives me looks or
anything or anything like that.
It's just a,
I'm told I'm not supposed to do this
but fuck it, I'm gonna do it anyway.
But there's stuff I wouldn't dare do.
- I like doing the reverse Gaijin card.
I like playing the Gaijin card
and then immediately after
I've committed the act
just bust out the Japanese.
Just like,
"Psyke."
- Reverse UNO.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Can you give us an
example of a situation?
- So an example of a situation,
I'm trying to think what would be,
I mean, something like that, right?
Like you're not allowed to eat on the go,
like not allowed to eat
on the train, for example,
where I would as you said,
sometimes I'm busy and sometimes
I got to get something down
before I catch the train.
So I would eat on the go
and people would kind of
just be like, whatever.
But then what I like to do
just to fuck with people
is I like to, I finished the food and then
just 'cause I love seeing
people's reactions to this.
I finished the food
and then I pretend to get in a phone call
and I just talk in Japanese a lot.
(laughing)
Because seeing the confused
phases of Japanese,
they will be like,
"Is he Gaijin or is he not Gaijin?
"I don't even know anymore,"
is my favorite pastime.
- I've done the exact same thing.
But just when I'm in Thailand
and you know when people gossip about you
in their native tongue
or they don't know that
you understand them
and you just want to
flex on them to be like,
"Bitch, I know exactly what
you motherfucking said.
"You better watch yourself, motherfucker."
- I've had so many experiences like that.
Especially, when you're outside of Tokyo
where they're obviously
not used to the foreigners.
I was in a supermarket
once with my sister.
We were like really, really young.
We were maybe like,
I'll spin maybe like nine or 10 years old.
And we were just in the aisle
that has all like the snacks and stuff.
Because Japanese and
snacks like fucking best.
And we were just picking stuff out
and there was this kid probably
around the same age as me,
who was just like staring at us
from down the aisle,
obviously because we looked foreign
and he'd obviously never seen
a foreign kid in his life.
So he was a staring and then
his other friend came up
and I could clearly hear that
they were like,
"Oh, look at these fucking foreigners."
It was to that-
- These are nine year old's.
(laughing)
- Yeah, legit.
They were like,
"Oh man, look at these foreigners.
"They look so weird."
Or something along that.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And I heard everything,
and I'm just like,
"Oh, you prepare for my backhand.
"Prepare for my nine-year-old backhand."
- "I've never decked
a nine-year-old before
"but today could be the day."
- I've never closed-line to anybody,
but man, you guys just
put on some distance"
So just to with them, I was like,
(foreign language)
My nine-year-old mind was like,
"I'll show them."
(laughing)
So, out loud to my sister.
I said, in Japanese, I said,
have you finished selecting
which one you want?
And I think my sister
quickly picked up on it too
because I think she overheard it.
And so she was like,
"All right, I'll play you a game."
(laughing)
And back in Japanese, she was like,
"Yeah, I've almost finished."
And then she busted out this really
like specific Japanese reference.
And from my periphery,
I'd never seen a nine-year-old
with a punk champ face in my life.
But it was just like,
"What?"
You would have thought these kids
would have seen like the face of God.
They were just like,
"Oh my God, what the fuck is that?"
And just to fuck with them even further
when we finished selecting our shit,
I purposely went towards the kids.
And as I passed by, I busted out a
(foreign language)
And that was just like
the finishing brawl.
That might as well,
I just clothes line them with my warriors.
- Even a death note asking counter-
- I'll do it.
I'll fucking kicked the fuck out of it.
- That's so much more like passive
than what I think I used to do to kids.
- Joey slammed down a nine year old
with Japanese and language, swish.
- I remember we used to go camping
every year in France for like three weeks.
I was, okay, you're
gonna think wild, Connor.
You're a violent like fucking 11 year old.
I fucking spent all my
time in the arcades.
I remember this one time
this kid had been taunting me
I guess French kid.
I fucking hated him.
Even taunting me for like days.
And I'm playing Metal Slug.
And you know how you would
put like two credits in?
- Yeah.
- You press the credit button?
- Yeah, yeah.
- So, I'm playing and I
put another one in for me
when I die,
this asshole, this 11 year old bitch
comes along presses the
restart credit button,
and then walks away.
And then I immediately just turned around
and just fucking smacked him in the face.
(laughing)
I got in so much trouble.
I had like an angry
French dad shouting at me.
I'm like 11, right?
His dad shouting at me.
So this kid's crying.
I'm like, I'm gonna finish my game.
(laughing)
And then I'll deal with this.
And my dad had such a fucking go at me.
- You were that X-Box kid.
- Which I definitely like.
I was such an angry kid.
I've no idea why, but I'm glad though.
'Cause now I just can't
even get angry with-
- To be fair, I'd be
pretty pissed off too.
If some random fucking kid
came up to me did that.
- Yeah, hen you were like 11, right?
This is also,
my parents didn't give me much money
and I would always use
it on the games, right?
So to me, this kid has just
taken like the only money
I was getting for like that whole trip.
And I was like, oh no.
Oh, no.
- We all know like two in 11 year old,
like two or three credits
or the little Slug
is the equivalency of mom's credit card.
- I fucking love Metal Slug
and that kid took my credit.
- No, I can totally
understand why you got angry.
I just thought,
man, there's a few steps
between taking someone's credit
and smacking someone in face.
- He been giving me shit...
(laughing)
This kid have been giving me shit,
'cause it's like a campsite.
He'd been giving me shit for days.
I was like, I'm done, dude.
I'm done.
I'm fuming.
I just straight up punched him.
I got so much shit for that.
And then like two days later,
the same kid who I punched
had a black eye,
he came while I was on
my other fucking game.
Just pulls out the plug
and I fucking chased him,
but he ran off.
I was gonna kill him.
I was gonna fucking kill him.
But he ran off.
(laughing)
Motherfucker just pulled out the plug
whilst I was mid Metal Slug.
- Wow.
- Yeah, man.
- I don't even remember...
This is going to be a weird question,
but when was the first time
you have a punched someone?
- But I got in so many fights in school.
- Was that the first time
you ever punched someone?
- Did you don't fight with...
Oh wait, do you only have a sister?
- I only had a sister.
- Oh dude, I have three brothers.
- Dude, if I punched my
sister, my dad would...
My dad used to say this one threat.
It's like a legit threat.
Where if I did anything like bad in public
he just grabbed my ear and
just whispered being like
"I brought you into this world,
I can easily take you out."
(laughing)
My dad won't remember that.
But I specifically...
To an eight year old that's like,
"I'm sorry father."
- Parenting 101, dad.
- Me and my brothers,
so we had the three brothers, right?
- Yeah.
- So it was WrestleMania,
like fucking constantly.
- Yeah, I bet.
- I must have been in fist fights
like three days of the week.
- Was actually fist fights or was it like-
- Oh yeah, we got to
the point we were like
actually start like full
on punching each other.
- Holy shit, man.
- We hated each other.
I love them now.
I love you guys.
But back then it was like, fuck it.
'Cause Oh God, so many fights.
But yeah, my dad had this
thing we called it like,
he's pretty gonna kill me if I say this,
but he had the single, the murder stare.
And when you started fucking up
and he would look at you
and he's like,
"Bro, you're one step away
from losing everything."
(laughing)
- I will end you right now.
- It was the look where he was like,
"Don't do it.
"Don't do one more thing.
"I'll end you."
(laughing)
- I love you dad, by the way.
- I was an only child
so I never had to grow
up with any siblings.
Never had to share anything.
- Yeah.
- But yeah, that was...
I had a fairly uneventful
childhood because of that.
- In 2020, we call that privilege.
(laughing)
- I got bullied so much in school,
so I just started just
fucking punching everyone back
- I guess yeah,
if you get bullied at school,
you put a lot of pain at young age.
- Yeah, I mean that's when I
first started punching back
and actually get in fights.
People just left me alone
'cause they knew if...
They would go for someone
else who wouldn't fight back.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Should have just challenged
them to a chess game.
- I should've, man,
that would have definitely
worked to get the kids.
- We'll play chess game
and then the moment you
win and you just punch him.
It's like double down on it.
Double check me.
- Oh my God, dude.
There so many times I
got in fights with kids.
I don't know what stories I could tell
if you want any, I mean-
- I'm just trying to think when was the...
- Do you ever punch anyone at school?
Like full on punch someone?
- Yeah, I have.
- For what reason?
- Because this kid in my-
- It's always dumbest fucking the school.
- Yeah, it's because this
kid in my high school
was giving me shit.
He was the bully of that year.
But the thing is he was
that one bully that,
you know how some bullies
are kind of like popular
with the kids that they don't bully
this kid because he bullied everybody.
Like every single person,
everybody fucking hated this kid.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
And of course eventually he the rounds
and the next target was
me for whatever reason,
but and obviously going to a high school
where it's 99% white boys
and I'm the only one with
a nonwhite bloodline.
- Of course, he's going for blood.
- He's going for the
low-hanging fruit essentially.
So he would say all these
late horribly racial slurs
at me and stuff
and just one day he was just really...
And I didn't mind the racial slurs,
it's when he got up to my face-
- I hate that so much.
- There's a difference between bully
shouting across the playground at you-
- And I don't mind that stuff.
- Which is fine,
because that shit's easy to ignore.
- But respect my personal space.
- Yeah, I was like,
the moment you cross
into my personal space,
that's when the hands come out.
And I never punched anyone in
my life up until that point.
And I was like,
"Okay, there's only one way
that this kid is gonna stop."
- I gotta teach this kid a lesson.
- And in my head I was doing a KG episode
where I'm like,
"If I punch him, I'm either going to die
or I'm gonna come out of this alive."
- Joey's like death-noting every action.
- But, this is like the total opposite
of the way I used to think about it.
I was like, just punch
and figure it out later.
- Oh, no, no, no.
I was always the person who was like,
"Okay, what's gonna happen
if I go down this route?"
It was like a visual novel
where I was like, punch or not punch.
And I was like,
"I don't know.
"I don't wanna have to ban.
"I don't wanna get the bad end, right?"
So I was always like,
there's a very good possibility that
if I punch I'm going to just like bad end.
It just came over.
And I was like,
"But this kid was just relentlessly
just shouting in my face and just like..."
And then the moment he started
pushing me around as well
that's when I think I just snapped.
And I just weighed all back
and just knock this kid in the chin.
I threw the fucking barking move on him.
Just like,
knocked him in the chin
and he fell down on the ground
and he just kind of walked off
and then nobody in my year fucked with me.
- That's good.
- And I was just like,
"Okay, oh?"
All right, that was a good end.
- This is more like...
I'd never recommend fighting back
'cause it can normally like,
it can go like two ways, right?
You can either fuck up
or everyone else will wanna challenge you.
Everyone's like,
"Oh, you think you're hot shit?
"All right."
- That's like the start of a anime.
" Oh, the nerd fall back?"
Dude, there were kids who would like
spit on each other at school.
That was the stuff that
bothered me the most.
You can call me shit,
but don't spit on me.
What the fuck?
I hated high school.
- Did you guys have this, I don't know if
this is only an Australian
high school thing,
but the last year of 12th grade,
literally the day before graduation,
I forgot what it was called.
I think it was called like G12 free day
where basically the 12th graders
for the last day of high school
they can just run around the school
and do whatever the fuck they want.
- I think we had something
similar in our school.
- What?
You guys didn't have that?
Like our school took
that free day literally
where some fucking
crazy shit would happen.
We somehow...
It started off quite innocently,
like putting lube all over the stair rails
and stuff like that so
people would slip on it.
And another one was going into
one of the teacher's offices
and filling his entire flow
with cups full of water.
- What?
- So that he could like go into his...
And then it got too far when one of,
I think it was like a group of boys,
they got one of the teachers' cars
and I don't know how the they did it.
I think it was driving a mini.
So it was like relatively small car.
And they somehow put the car
on top of one of the school buildings,
like on the roof.
- What?
- And I mean, that's too far
but that's just sounds impressive.
- Honestly, the engineering.
These kids going places.
- I wasn't there to witness it,
but imagine just walking to school
and you're walking along the school wall
and you just look up and there's
just a car sitting there.
I was like,
"Huh, how did that get there?"
- This must have been in
the news or some shit.
- Non, no, no.
This is quite frequent.
- That sounds like a
scene from some American-
- Frequent?
What do you mean frequent?
- This sounds like a scene
from some American high school movie
that you watch and you're like,
"Oh, this is so fucking stupid.
"This will never happen in real life."
I don't know if my high
school still does it, but-
- That's newsworthy in the UK, I think.
That would be,
yeah, of course.
Fucking hell.
- Even the goal schools would go crazy
like that as well just-
- What the fuck?
We didn't have any of this.
- Because it was the last,
last day of high school.
So it's like, do whatever the
fuck you want while you can
because after this day you
have adult responsibility.
So it's the Miley Cyrus effect, right?
It's like, just get
all that out of the way
once the contract has ended
and you're good to go.
- But like I said, he must've
learned some good skills
from being able to fucking
get a mini on a school roof.
- Yeah.
- How would you do that even if-
- It wasn't like a multi-story building,
it was like a demountable.
So it was just getting it up, but still.
- How?
Did like eight of them
coordinate this lift?
- I don't know.
I wasn't there to witness
it, but it was awesome
just staring across the school grounds
and seeing a fucking mini
on top of a demountable.
That was crazy.
- How do you convince kids to join,
" Yeah, so we gonna go
lift the teachers mini.
"Yeah, you down?"
- "I need like five boys who's in."
It's like,
"All right, let's fucking do it."
- Speaking of like high school,
why is there so many high school anime?
You know what I mean?
- Wow, that transition gone, damn.
- I was just mad-
- Holy shit, he's on it.
- I'm fucking on it.
- What's the deal with high school anime?
What's the deal with high school anime?
- Because that sounds crazier
than any fucking high school anime
I've ever heard of-
- I don't know, some crazy
high school anime out there.
- It's either one or two ways.
It's either like the most vanilla-
- Did you guys have school
festivals in your high school?
Like how they have in Japan?
I think that's only Japanese
high school thing, isn't it?
- In Japan, they make school looks so fun.
And British school are the
most depressing shit on earth.
- Oh no, I like it.
- They don't do anything.
- You guys are here telling
your high school stories.
I don't remember a fuck..
I remember fuck off my high school.
- All I remember is bad, bad, bad things.
- See, people always say
that, I think I like the 1%
that actually had a good
time in high school.
- I think I had a good...
I liked my friend group a lot
that I had those four of us
and we were all really close,
but stuff that happened in
school was just always awful.
- Like it was what?
- I don't know.
I got in so many fights as a kid.
I don't know why.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Like there was one time as well,
this is one story I remember.
And this drove my blood
life through the roof, dude.
- Yeah.
- So there's a day in the UK,
I don't know if you do this in Australia
where the kids who are
coming into high school
get like two days in like June,
before September starts.
Where they get to just
come and see the school.
And my little brother
was coming up, right?
- Oh, like an orientation.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So I was showing my little brother around.
I'm one of the guys just, the bullies
just comes up to me while I'm
talking to my little brother
just slaps me in the face.
- What?
- Just slapped me in the face.
And I'd already been in
multiple fights at this point.
- Right.
- And me, I get slapped down like,
"All right, it's go time."
(laughing)
- The hands are coming out.
- You slapped me first.
I'm not gonna get in
shit now if I beat you.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, I started fighting him and I-
- In front of your little brother?
- This is so weird to me.
In what world is this just-
- He literally-
- Does this thing just happen?
- Literally just slaps me.
And then I'm like,
"Wait there."
(laughing)
'Cause I was thinking,
I've got to show my little brother
I'm not a pussy, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- He's my little brother.
He looks up to me.
I've got to show him I'm not a bitch.
'Cause if he see we get
slapped and I'm like,
"Oh, sorry, sorry."
He's gonna think,
"Wow, my big brother is kind of wimp.
" What's up with that?"
- It sounds like a inbetweeners
episode or something.
- It is, because then it
turns to a tournament arc
where then all his friends
the next day we're like,
"Oh well, we want to turn now."
(laughing)
Jesus Christ.
And there was one time,
and this is pretty the
one where I felt most bad
is that this guy came up to me.
He's like kind of chubby and I thought,
"What are you doing?
"What are you doing, man?
"What's up with this?"
He pushes me once.
And I was like,
"All right, fine."
I grabbed his head and
just fucking knee him.
Bear in mind...
Okay, I do not do not condone
violence in any sense, but-
- But I loved it.
- I was such an angry 13 year old
'cause I was getting bullied since like-
- You were 13 when you did this?
- Yeah.
- What the fuck?
You weren't even in high school,
you were like middle school.
- No, not like 13, like 15, 14, maybe 15.
- Yes, still.
- 15, yeah.
Then this guy didn't...
I've never had a problem with this guy.
I didn't realize why
he was doing this to me
but I think I pissed
off one of his friends
and then he was trying to act big.
I don't think he actually wanted to fight.
He was just pushing me
around, but I was like,
"Fuck it."
Anyway, so I did that and he
just dropped and I was like,
"Oh no.
"I'm gonna be in a lot of trouble."
I don't think I did it that hard.
I just thought,
I saw it in a movie once it
looked really fucking cool.
(laughing)
- I saw him do it once, I can do it too."
- "Who gets hurt by getting
kneeled in the face?"
(laughing)
- He's was like,
he's smaller than me.
(laughing)
So he pushed me and then I
think I was gonna go push,
I just went like,
And he just dropped for like five seconds.
And I was like,
"Oh, shit, are you okay?"
And he was like,
"Yeah, yeah, I'm fine."
And I think he was so embarrassed,
he didn't tell anyone.
- Right.
- And then he came in the
next day, two black eyes.
- Wait, how did he get to two black eyes?
- How wide is your kneel?
(laughing)
'cause I feel like I hit right here.
- Oh, okay.
- I was gonna say-
- So he came in with two black eyes.
Didn't tell anyone, but all
my friends knew what happened.
No one said anything.
It was like that one week
where I had like three fights, right?
No one did anything for me.
The rest of my school life.
It was great.
Everyone was nice to me after that.
- You had more fights in that one week
than I think I have in my entire life.
- I think I had more
fights in that one week
than anyone else-
- This is like fight club.
- In my school it wasn't
about getting into fights.
It was about who did you know?
If you're cool with X person,
if you're cool with that person,
he wouldn't fuck with you.
- I don't know if it's 'cause
it's like a small town thing.
It was such a small town thing
and where the teachers often
forgave the shitty behavior
'cause more often than not
all the teachers were friends
with the kids' parents, right?
- Yeah.
- So it was kind of a thing of like,
"Oh, don't do it again.
"Don't do it again."
- You need someone in the face-
- Every single time it was like,
"Don't do it again.
"Don't do it again."
- There wasn't a proper punishment?
- I mean, it is what it is.
I don't really care now.
I dealt with it myself.
- Did you go to a boy's school?
- No.
- Oh, okay.
So maybe that's the aspect of it, right?
Because I feel that boys
will be more willing to get into fights
if it's a coed school
because they're trying
to impress the girls.
- I never wanted to.
I just wanted to play my games and be-
- Yeah, but it just seems
like fucking fight club.
- Honestly, it was fucking awful.
I joke about it,
but I remember hating
it when I was in school.
- I probably fucking hate
it too if it was that-
- Yeah, yeah.
- And I remember there was
one guy who would like...
He didn't wanna fight me.
He didn't want to fight me.
I think he knew that he'd get hurt.
So he would just,
or like I said, he would spit on me
and anytime I tried to like
fight him, he just run away.
So what can I do?
It's like that one asshole
who like kites amazingly, he's like,
"Come to me."
- His torn games like on point.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And he'd just kite you and he-
- He was just kitting me, I'm like,
"Fucking stop.
"Stop"
Actually he'd run to
an area with teachers,
and I can't fucking punch
him in front of a teacher.
- He'd make a amazing ADC anime, man.
- Yeah, yeah.
He'd make a great one.
I swear.
I'm behind, man.
I'm just like,
"Me fight?
"Don't think?"
But like no, I wouldn't...
Okay, if any 13 year old,
14 old kids, don't fight.
It's not a good solution.
- It's not worthy it.
- I mean, I was just lucky
that I was freakishly strong
for a 12, 13 year old as well.
That helped a lot.
- Yeah.
I don't know, 'cause for me
I've always gone through life being like,
okay, physical interaction
is always my last choice.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I have that now.
But as a kid, I felt like
it was my only, you know?
- You went the hard way.
- Yeah, I mean, I'm glad
that I was angry as a kid
'cause now I have like zero anger at all.
I never get angry about shit now.
And I'm so glad that I just
got that shit out, you know?
- Yeah.
- I don't know if that's how anger works.
I don't know if this is science.
- Not sure about that, it's-
- But I feel like 'cause
I've dealt with so much anger
in my past I've been able to really,
I don't know.
- Fucking channel it right.
- It's like filled your
anger quota of life
during your teens, and it's like-
- I think so.
- So I'm run dry now.
I genuinely think I have that.
I don't know, I don't feel-
- You just go down the system now.
I get like mildly frustrated at things.
Like a British person would,
but I never get angry at things.
- Mildly frustrated is just the British...
That's just the default British emotion.
Anything can be mildly frustrate you,
and that's just the way
we've just grown up.
- Yeah.
I'll be angry about shit now,
but I'll be like angry
I play it up 'cause I liked your shouting,
but is like the chillest man on earth.
Like it's impossible to get mad.
I've never actually seen you mad.
- Well, I mean that's the
whole monk thing, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Do you want to talk about it?
- Oh, fuck.
- Have we talked about that in a podcast?
- Oh, okay.
I guess I got to tell the story now.
- That was a smooth
transition, you see that boys?
- I'm gonna get to the toilet before.
- He needs to santa up.
(foreign language)
- Damn that was-
(laughing)
Am I watching an anime right now?
Damn, son.
- What are we talking about today, Joe?
- We're talking about
two particular series
that Book Walker is
releasing on their website.
I don't know if you've
heard of it, Connor?
I'm sure Garnt you've heard of
it, but there is two series.
There's one called TenPuru,
which is about a temple.
Surprise, surprise.
- With a monk.
Perfect segue into the
next part of the show.
But also the other one is
(foreign language)
which I don't know what
the English title of is-
- Why the Hell Are You Here Teacher?
- That's it.
- I've seen episode one of this show.
Oh my goodness gracious
that is not Christian,
but I'm so glad I can
read it on Book Walker
in the comfort of my home.
- Yes, 'cause on Book Walker,
the manga is completely uncensored.
You get full nibs and everything.
If you've ever thought about
getting with your teacher.
That's basically the show.
That's basically the manga.
- I need no more.
- You might need more
because the other manga that
they have it is TenPuru,
which is illustrated by the same guy.
No, sorry, yeah.
Illustrated by the same
guy who did Grand Blue.
You know Grand Blue?
- I do know Grand Blue.
- Yeah, so illustrated
by the complete same guy
just different writer.
But essentially as the name
suggests it's about this kid
who has these really dirty thoughts
but he wants to be a good Christian.
So he basically goes to it a temple
to get rid of this horny
on main Christian thoughts.
But the problem is is
that he becomes a monk
at a temple that is full of hot women.
- That doesn't sound very monkly to me.
- It doesn't happen to you?
(laughing)
- I wanna be a monk, I swear.
- This was the real
reason I became the monk.
- Hoping for that scenario.
- That's sounds pretty good.
- Yeah, yeah.
But the thing is
because it's illustrated by the same guy
to Grand Blue, the type of comedy
is exactly the same as Grand Blue.
So you love the like really vulgar visual
that really made Grand Blue funny,
TenPuru is exactly the same way.
And the added bonus is that
it's way more hot girls ain
TenPuru than Grand Blue so.
- Guys, I'm getting some breaking
news from Book Walker here
both the TenPuru and Why the
Hell Are You Here Teacher
are exclusive to Book
Walker until August 13th.
You can read half a Volume
One of both titles for free.
Free gentlemen, free
or buy them for 50% off.
(laughing)
Can we keep that, Adrey?
Yes.
And lastly, Volume Two of Why
the Hell Are You Here Teacher
comes with a Book Walker
exclusive colored booklet.
and in brackets they've said here,
extra ecchi, gentlemen.
- Extra ecchi?
- I don't know what that means.
- I don't know if my
penis can handle that.
- How can it get extra ecchi?
- What's the extraness in the ecchiness?
- It's that the skin is colored this time.
It's not as black and white.
- If that sounds remotely
interesting to you.
You can check it out in the link below.
- Thank you to Book Walker
sponsoring today's video.
- If you want more
sponsor reads like that,
please actually go ahead and
go check out these books.
They are actually amazing.
And we love doing these silly ad reads.
If you like it, please go to support them.
Show them that these ad reads work.
Thank you.
Back to the video.
- So yeah, it's a little known secrets
or it's a little known fact
that I've been a monk in my life
but I've not just been a monk once.
- Just saying that is so cool.
- To me, this is just
part of Buddhist culture.
So in Buddhist culture,
normally when you want to
give your family like good karma,
everyone in my family has been a monk
like twice in their life.
Once when they're a teenager.
And once when they're like an adult.
So you become a monk
once when you're like a teenager.
We call that (indistinct)
and then you become a full
monk when you become an adult
and that's when you kind
of hit like your early 20s.
- Okay, okay.
- So yeah, so normally a lot
of people would just do it
for like one or two days
'cause we believe that it's good karma.
- Yeah.
- I remember when I was about 12 or 13
I was a monk for two weeks.
And then afterwards,
when I was about 22, 23
I was a monk for a full month.
- Jeez.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause you told me stories about
how you are a monk for an entire month
but I never knew that you did it twice.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
I mean, to me it's just part
of like being a Buddhist
and trying to get...
I was that good little Asian kid.
I was trying to give like my family
good karma and everything.
But I honestly liked the experience
'cause it was...
I'm not joking when it was literally
the life changing experience for me.
That was me before being a monk.
And then there's me after being a monk
because normally people would
just do it just to impress
their family and just give
their family a good karma.
But I told my mom,
if I'm gonna do it,
I'm gonna go all the way.
There's some temples that you go
to that don't take it as seriously.
And then I went to a
fucking hardcore temple
where we didn't have any
technology, we had to...
Okay, so here here's my daily schedule.
So I would have to wake
up at around 4:00 AM.
- That already sounds like torture.
That already sounds like torture.
- I have to be ready,
have to be completely ready by five.
And we didn't have any beds.
We had a concrete floor
and one little pillow to sleep on.
And we had the thinnest
blanket in the world,
which wasn't so bad 'cause it's Thailand.
But when sometimes when you're sleeping
in the middle of the forest,
'cause there would be
times when we just go out
to your temple in the
middle of the forest.
You can get fucking cold.
The temperature drops
to about two or three degrees sometimes.
And you just have this
like tiny little blanket
on a concrete floor to keep you warm.
So we'd have to wake up by
four, get ready by five.
And then we just be like
meditating and praying
for a good two, three hours every day.
And then afterwards we
would basically go out,
barefoot, go to whatever village
or whatever area around the temple.
And people would just
donate the food to...
We would carry like these
little baskets on our necks
and people would come over
and they would donate food
or whatever they wanna
donate because we believe
that if you give two a monk,
that's a good karma as well.
So the food that we got donated,
that's what we would eat.
So we would walk around for a few hours-
- The entire day?
- Yeah, For the entire day.
- Did you get a lot of it or
was it like just enough or?
- I mean, you get what you're given.
You have no choice about
what you could eat.
You could eat basically
what you were given.
Did you ever get anything
like super nasty?
- No, I mean, it's-
- In the mindset, you're
not like picky and like,
"Oh really?
"A Snickers?
"Really?"
- No, because the whole
point of being a monk
is that you live-
- You don't care.
You eat to survive.
I guess if you're caring
about that that's like-
- That's the feet and
the point of being a monk
So you get what you're given
and you live the simplest life
you can possibly live and
you basically eat to survive
and you get one meal a day.
And you gotta be okay with
whatever you get given.
So we would eat at around 11 to 12 o'clock
and that would be our
first and only meal a day.
It was easier when you're a kid monk
'cause kid monks would
get two meals a day.
- But when you're grown.
- Yeah, when you're adult
when you're more grown up
burning more calories,
no you got to survive
on one meal a day.
And afterwards you could...
There was no cheesing.
So after that you couldn't have any milk
or any like liquids that had calories
you could only have water
or some kinds of fruit juices.
And that was it.
And, yeah, It was very...
I don't know really how to
describe the experience.
'Cause imagine if you just take
every distraction out of your life
and you just live the
simplest life possible
you don't eat to enjoy your food.
You don't really get the pleasures in life
but at the same time, you just kind of
you're okay with everything
'cause you have to be
okay with everything.
And I remember for the
first week of being a monk,
it's fucking hard.
It is so fucking hard
to reprogram your brain
to not only be like,
"Okay, how do I distract
myself with my phone?
"How do I not check Twitter?
"How do I not watch YouTube videos?
"How do I just be okay
with my own thoughts?"
And it's so hard
because nowadays your brain
constantly looks forward to something.
It constantly needs
something to distract itself.
And the first week I was just kind of
like a drug addict, right?
(laughing)
- I should have tweaked.
Give me a tweak
- I'm sitting there trying to meditate
and my mind just going out
a million miles an hour.
I haven't watched TV in a week.
I haven't seen a screen in a week.
It's very, very difficult.
But the more time you do it,
the more you kind of you realize that,
oh, these are all just distractions.
You can be completely
okay with just yourself
and your own thoughts and
just doing the simplest things
and life activities.
And then when I got to that point
I kind of just had time to
just reflect on my entire life.
'Cause what else are you gonna fucking do
when you have nothing to do
but literally think back
about every decision
that you've made in your life.
And the way your mind works,
you know when sometimes you're
lying in bed at 11:00 AM
and your brain reminds you
about the embarrassing thing
you did when you were 12
or maybe by that time when
you punched a fucking kid?
- I'm like,
"I gotta-
- So just imagine your
entire day just being that
just being like,
"Ah, I wonder if I'd made the right choice
"at this point in my life."
And then what happened to me was that
I kind of just reflected
on every little decision
that kind of led me up
to this point in my life.
And what it made me,
what it forced me to do was really think,
"Huh, am I really happy
about where I am now?
"What's my life gonna be like
when this monk had ends?"
And I was at a really bad point in my life
before I became a monk,
which is kind of why I
really wanted to commit
to the facts of being like,
if I was gonna be a monk,
I'm gonna go all the way,
get the full detox, you know?
'Cause I've seen some temples, you walk in
and they have like a 50 inch flat screen.
And I'm like,
"Does this-"
- The monk channel only.
We only have the monk channel.
- This doesn't seem very monkly to me.
I don't know about that.
- We accept PayPal transactions.
- It's on the TV,
on it's like a live stream
of a different temple
and then French.
- Exactly.
- Nice, nice content.
- So it forced me to just
reflect on my entire life.
And it forced me to really think about
what I wanted to do
after my monkhood ended.
So it was truly a,
I don't want to say fucking...
It was a spiritual journey
and I really just discovered myself-
- I mean, I think in this instance you can
because it nearly sounds like it.
- It kind of was.
I don't know.
You're like, it's-
- Just like me when I go to the toilet
without my phone, I'm like,
"I'm free"
(laughing)
- Because people have talked to me about
how they've had similar experiences
when they just shut off social media
and everything like that.
And I'm just like-
- You don't even know.
You won't even know.
" Bruh, you don't even know."
- Get on my level.
- Get on my level, bro.
You didn't have any board games.
You didn't have any cards
to just play around.
All you just had was just yourself.
And I can't really
convey how alien that is
because it was alien for me as well.
- There is a part of
me that just a vision,
'cause as you said,
the only thing you had was
just yourself and your mind.
And all I could imagine
was just, a monk guy
just sitting there
and just thinking of a funny
jokes in the locker room.
(laughing)
- No, no, no.
That totally happened as well.
When I was a monk, that's
when I thought about,
"There's a series I wanna
make called Anime in Minutes."
- Are you serious right now?
- I'm totally serious.
I'm totally serious.
That came to me,
I remember the exact moment,
'cause I was just walking around,
I'm walking around one
of the Thai villages
and it just fucking came to me.
'Cause I remember last,
not last week but a few weeks ago
I talked about being Zen on
the fucking toilet in a shower.
So that was I kind of...
Sometimes when I'm just walking
and I'm just zoning out.
Sometimes I've reached this point when
a lot of ideas just come to me
and it came to me when
I was a monk as well.
And I got a lot of video ideas
and a lot of ideas when I was a monk,
which it was these ideas when I was a monk
that have developed to me
to my comeback on YouTube,
where I figured out,
okay, if I'm gonna come back on YouTube,
how was I gonna come back on YouTube.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But yeah, this has been a
very closely guarded secret
because there were some YouTube,
some very odd YouTube clips
where I'm just wearing a beanie.
And nobody knows why I'm
just wearing a beanie.
And it was because I had
just finished my monkhood
and I was just completely bold.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What if they just like took
it in a really dark direction?
It's like,
"Oh no, the cancer treatment."
- Yeah, how do you sign up to be a monk?
Is it like a Facebook group, you're like,
" I wanna be a monk."
Do you just rock up and be like,
"Yo, let's do it."
- Yeah, I mean you just
turn up to whatever temple
you want to become a monk.
And they're like...
okay, you go to the head monk
and you request to be a monk.
And they ask, okay,
before you become a monk
you need to make sure you
have no outstanding debts.
You basically, you've got to
give up or material connections
to the world before you can
commit to becoming a monk.
And you'll have this
interview now you're like,
okay, if you're gonna become a monk,
you got to do this, do this, do this.
- You know what would
be a really cool idea
for this channel is if
like us three somehow
went to a temple here and
just like experienced it
for like a single that day.
Wow, I was just already on that shit.
Hey, if you guys would like to see that.
- Monk episode when?
- Monk episode, like Garnt could be
like head monk of trash taste.
- We have to shave our heads.
Did you realize that, Joey?
- Shit.
I just noticed that.
- I can commit to that, you can't.
- I can't commit to that.
I'll just wear the beanie.
- But I don't really talk about it
but now by now that I am,
I do like highly recommend
that kind of experience.
So or just do it doing
'Cause you don't notice
how distracting life is.
You don't realize that
as soon as you wake up
you've got things to occupy your mind.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You got your job or you got,
the first thing you do
is you check Twitter,
open Arknights and you
don't know how crazy
your mind can be sometimes.
So, you've literally
remove every distraction,
every commitments that you need
to do from your daily life.
And you just have nothing
'cause it's just a void, right?
You're just giving you life a void.
And because you give your life a void,
it fucking changes you.
I don't know.
I don't know how else I can-
- I totally get that.
Back when I was still doing YouTube stuff,
I went on this like camping trip
with a few of my friends
and we went to this area
that had absolutely no
reception whatsoever.
- Oh, Wales?
(laughing)
- Yeah, we went all the way to Wales.
No, we were just
in the butt fuck middle
of nowhere in Australia
with no reception.
And we would just went camping.
And because there's no reception,
I couldn't shake anything.
I couldn't like message you.
- This is like a lite version.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's basically just like
dieting, diet version of it.
But I kind of had like a
similar experience with that.
But only like for that one day
and I remember the first couple of hours,
I fucking hated it.
'Cause I was just, I was
getting those like drugs like,
"I need to know who liked my tweet."
But after a while, when
I hit around midday,
I eventually was like,
"You know what?
"This is actually really nice.
"The world is beautiful."
- That's why I love going to the cinema.
No one can like, be like,
"Why don't you answer your phone?"
- Yeah.
- In every other situation,
"Oh, you should have answered still."
But in the cinema for some reason,
They're like,
"Understandable.
"Have a nice day."
"You ignored my texts for three hours"
"Understandable."
- You're just like a void.
- It's great, I love it.
You just literally ignore the world
for like three hours and just have fun.
- Yeah, and that's why
it frustrates me when
the void gets pulled back to reality
when someone in the back
is just fucking shouting.
I just be like,
"Oh, yeah, I forgot this is reality."
I hate it.
- Because especially now I think,
I don't know the Internet's
I feel like has reprogrammed
my brain in a way.
- Definitely.
I don't remember,
I don't know if I just have ADHD
because I didn't always felt like
I was this easily distracted.
- It's like subconsciously
building patents
in your head thou.
You've trained your brain
to check Twitter constantly.
And you will have that moment
and I'm sure you've all had it
where you're like you,
open Twitter, you close Twitter
and you open Twitter again.
And then you're like,
"Why did I open Twitter again?"
- Yeah.
- I don't know why.
- I literally just refreshed
my feed like two seconds ago.
I didn't wanna to do this.
I just didn't.
- You check Twitter on your computer
and you realize there's nothing to changed
and then you close and you
immediately checking your phone.
- "Why am I doing this?"
I wasted ten seconds.
- It's the same as course
as going to the fridge,
see nothing, then closing it,
sitting on back on the couch.
And then five minutes later
then go to the fridge.
- Yeah.
- It's like food's gonna
magically appear in the fridge.
- Yeah.
- So, I mean, it was an
awesome experience to me.
I don't, if that's not something that's...
it's not an experience for everyone.
- The question is though,
would you do it again?
- I would do it again possibly.
Maybe not to this extreme
because I feel like I'm in a
lot better place in my life.
- I'm a lot more privileged.
(laughing)
- No, I mean, not just that, but mentally.
I'm in a lot better
place in my life as well.
So I don't feel, I would need
to go to that extreme again
but would I want an experience
where I just kind of just
remove myself from the world
and just give myself-
- Yeah, just like a short detox.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's like a detoxing the mind.
- It's how I feel it.
And I highly recommend people doing that.
It sounds really cheesy
because people will always think of that
like some crazy California-
- Gap year.
(laughing)
- I took a gap year to Thailand.
- Exactly that, right?
- It's just like,
"Shut up, dude.
You probably went to the club every night.
"Shut up."
- Yeah.
So that's why I don't
really like to talk about it
because whenever you say,
yeah, I've been a monk-
- It sounds pretentious.
People give you that look to be like, why-
- 'Cause it makes it sound like
it was like a vacation for you,
whereas it was pretty, right?
- Yeah.
- That's why it sounds pretentious.
- Or maybe it sounds like it
because maybe some people
think you just went through
adjust to brag about it later on.
The fact that you don't
really talk about this.
- I never talk about this-
- I remember I dragged that
conversation out of you
but we were really drunk in Singapore
like three years ago.
- I think I just drunkenly
offhanded mentioned it.
- I was like,
"Hold on, you were a monk?"
(laughing)
- Were you ever angry
before you were a monk?
Because I swear, I've
never seen you angry.
What's up with that, Garnt?
- I mean, I've been angry before, but-
- You don't get...
Even when you're angry, I'm like,
dude, I don't know if you're
angry, angry or maybe-
- No, being a monk just taught me how to
think about the whole process.
Basically, process everything, right?
'Cause when you just kind
of empty your mind part of
the commitment we tried to make is that
we tried to learn how we
process our way of thinking.
And you gotta kind of...
So the way I see it, it's
kind of like a logic tree.
And this is what happened
to me when I was a monk
where I'd feel certain
emotions I need to have to
like logically think be like,
Why am I feeling this?
How did this come?
And then you kind of learned the roots
of basically all your
emotions and just anger.
And then through that I just on the fly
I learned how to deal with my anger.
I would find another route to be like,
okay, before I get angry
maybe I could try dealing
it with another way,
which is why I've rarely get angry.
Some people get angry
very easily but for me,
it's not that I don't get angry
is that I just have
different ways of dealing
about it than shouting or fucking-
- I just love shouting, man.
I don't punch anyone anymore.
That's old Connor.
Old Connor's gone, new Connor
he just West coast it and shouts loudly.
- I love shouting.
When I shout, I fucking love shouting.
(laughing)
- I don't know why shouting is so fun.
- So is the deal like purposely shout
to just get that frustration
out before it turns
into legit anger or?
- Sometimes if I'm like
real angry some days,
or I wake up and I'm upset,
I'll just go in the
mirror and I'll be like,
"Come on."
(laughing)
- I only see that in movies, right?
I wouldn't be surprised if
you're the kind of person
who just punches the pillow.
Let's get all the frustration out, but-
- I just imagined you
in the fucking morning every morning-
- Do it.
- Like in the mirror,
"You got this Connor.
"You got this.
"You fucking got this."
- Okay, some days you wake up,
you'll feel like,
"Man, I'm kind of feeling
shitty today, man.
"I don't know why, man.
"I'm kind of worthless."
I get in front of that mirror, I'm like,
"You can do this."
My neighbors probably hate me.
Fuck it, I'm hype.
I'm ready for the day.
That energy rushes through you.
I feel like a 10 immediately.
- It's so monkey but I love it.
- I feel like a 10 straight
away to start my day.
- Question for you guys,
how did you guys hype yourself up
before recording session for your videos?
'Cause there's gonna be a time.
- Okay, okay, okay.
This is the thing that...
I think this is because
you've just recently
started doing it a lot, right?
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I remember when
I first started filming my face a lot,
I fucking dreaded doing it.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
- I did everything to avoid it.
I would shave like three times
just to make sure it
was perfect in my head,
but really what I was
doing with delaying it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Where I'm like,
"Maybe I need to go get
the groceries actually.
"I should do laundry actually.
"Oh, its too late vocal record now."
- I can't record 'cause I was too busy
renovating my house.
- But now I just turn it on and do it.
I don't have to think about it.
- I don't really hype myself up-
- I have a coffee, maybe
a red bull if I need it,
but that's about it.
- Yeah, caffeine helps definitely.
But I don't really have like a,
"Do it face."
- In the morning, if you're
feeling down man, try it.
Next time you feel sad when you wake up.
'Cause it happens sometime, man.
You just feel.
Just try it.
You'll feel like an idiot at first
but then you'll be like,
"Nice dude."
- It's gonna clown on me the entire day.
- I was about to say,
Sydney gonna be like-
- I guess since no one lives with me,
so it's like-
- Yeah, you can do it by yourself, but if-
- Sydney's like,
"Garnt, what're doing?
"Why you saying, come on?"
- Do it.
Do it.
- Don't let your dreams take you.
- Come.
- Yeah, come, come.
(laughing)
- I've realized I'm slowly
forming a profile for me
of just like a complete
monkey on this one.
- I think only hyping up by doing maybe,
sometimes because I'm not
going to even think about
recording a video, if I'm
already not in that state.
- Yeah, I've realized
just don't film if you're not in the mood.
- So, before I used to have to be like,
"Okay, I have to fucking
record something."
And then I would turn the camera on.
And immediately, the moment
you hit that record button,
you're just like,
"Fuck man, I don't wanna do it."
- You're like,
"I hate my life right now."
- It's like,
"Not today."
But I didn't have a choice
because I was uploading
every two days or something.
But with my current schedule
now I have a little bit levity in that.
I just know if I wake up in the morning
and today's the day where I
can just get something out.
Because if I feel good already
from the morning, then I'm like,
"All right, it's time to
get that bread game is late.
"Let's let's record like three videos.
"Just get that shit
while the fucking wild
hype train is running."
- Sometimes playing hype
music will get me in the zone.
- Just a nice funk, then
those beats they hit you-
- Dude, like power of music, man,
that shit can easily hype enough.
- How'd you know what
music to pick, Connor?
How'd you know what music to pick?
- I let YouTube decide for me.
(laughing)
- Do I go with slow beat or fast beat?
- Fast song, happy.
(laughing)
- YouTube search history
for music is just like an AI
trying to understand
what the emotions are.
- This is how my music tastes
works and how I find songs.
I like one song
and then I'll just keep letting
YouTube suggest me songs
and I'll keep building.
I never actively look out for songs.
I just let it suggest it the songs.
- It's like YouTube and
Spotify recommendations
were built for people like you.
- Oh dude, they're amazing, man.
- It's really fucking good thou, man.
- I was diehard Spotify for
like six years, maybe longer.
And then I just tried YouTube music once
'cause I had it with
premium and I was like,
"Holy shit, I think I like this more."
- Oh dude, but I've
discovered so much good music
on Spotify on recommended.
- I think both.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- 'Cause there's a lot of songs
that aren't official
that you'll get on YouTube music,
the like remixes that
will never be on Spotify
'cause they wouldn't-
- I don't really give
a shit about the remix-
- There so many good ones.
There's like one where it's
like the Sono Chino Sadame
makes for like that 90 song by
like Diana Ross or something.
- That shit claps, man.
Oh, I'll send you a link.
- What?
- There's always the good anime remixes.
- Dude, there are so
many good anime remixes
on YouTube that you're
not allowed on Spotify.
Sometimes I want to
listen to like Daft Punk.
But I also want to have
that animates remixes.
So I can do that on YouTube.
Hell, yeah.
- Dude, I've recently kind
of gone into the rabbit hole
of these insane like music remixes
and not just like anime,
obviously you know the anime remixes,
like everyone's seen
the Renai Circulation,
which has Snoop Dogg or whatever.
But my friend sent me one the other day,
which is fucking insane.
It was September by Earth, Wind & Fire
remixed with Crazy Train by Ozzy Osbourne.
- You can remix that song
with anything though.
- Yeah, but it sounded fucking amazing.
I was like,
"Oh my God, I need more.
"I need more."
- I have never seen an Earth,
Wind & Fire remix, September.
They disappoint me.
Except for the Taylor Swift
and that was terrible.
- But Earth, Wind & Fire
goes with everything.
- The Wii Show one, have you seen that?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Bro, that shit that collapsed, bro.
I can't do it.
I will get a copyright.
(laughing)
- But you just like,
"Damn that was too perfect."
That was kind of own pitch.
Connor was like,
"Did I get off pitch there."
- I've recently fallen
into the rabbit hole
of just listening to J-pop that's...
They sound like anime opening
and endings, but they're not.
- Like Polkadot Stingray?
- Oh yeah like Polkadot Stingray,
Zutomayo, Minami it's-
- It's so many.
- It's like the rabbit hole, right?
You discover one?
The algorithm is like,
"Oh, you like this?
"Oh, hello, let me show you more."
It's gotten so deep right.
That recently I was recommended a video,
which it was kind of like
a vocaloid kind of remix
but I think it was original song
but the video had no title
and the channel had no title
and then I click on it.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah so it's not even like
they have a space or something.
No, there's just literally
no character for the title.
- You can do that?
- Apparently you can.
- There's a thing called like
a Hoff Hoff space or something
it's a space that is
technically a character
but it doesn't show up as anything.
- You can't like highlight it
and copy and paste into the search bar.
There's no interaction
with whatever character
they're putting down.
So the only way people would have got this
is through recommendations
and the video has like two million views.
It's just insane.
And then I click on it
and then everyone's like,
"Oh, welcome to the cult."
(laughing)
- Join us.
- I see you have been the chosen one.
It's great because like they're probably
gonna kill me now because
everyone's like mutually agreed
not to talk about this which...
Sorry guys, I guess the
entire internet knows now.
Well, I'm not gonna link to it.
If you're part of the chosen
like show me a message.
If I see anyone linking
it we'll fucking bun you.
- You played me this in your house
and I was just hoping one day
would pop up in my record.
Still waiting, still waiting.
- It's like Illumina argument.
You just got to wait for that email.
- Cook some more crappy vocal
and can I get a pop up dude.
- No, but that's just the
wonders of the algorithm.
I mean, I have no idea
how the algorithm works.
Okay going completely off topic here.
But there's been one
video of mine recently
(laughing)
that's just been getting
recommended to everyone.
And I have no idea why it's
an eight year old video
that we've not talked
about on this podcast.
- So many people have tweeted us about it.
I'm just like, wow.
- Yeah, so there's been a video recently
that's been circulating that's called...
- Recently at the time of filming?
- Yeah recently at the time of filming
it might still be
circulating, talking about it.
It's probably gonna start getting stuck.
So I should probably circle back
to the start of animetube itself.
You guys are about to
get history lesson here.
- Go on.
- So, okay.
So do you guys know who the
very first Animetuber is?
- I thought it was Mr. Anime.
That was my preconception.
- I'd be surprised if
anyone watching this knew
because that means you've
been around for as long as me
but the very first anime
YouTuber is this guy
called Hards Anime Reviews.
And he started in 2006 and
he would just basically make
very basic animal reviews with like
his camera was like up here.
- Worst angle.
- Yeah, yeah was like kind of like
the worst angle you can think of.
- The angle we all start at, right?
- And he's now quit it's funny because
I tried to search him up and
see if he's still around.
And his first original
channel got terminated
as everyone's dead back then
when they were reviewing anime
and his second channel is called
un ironically the Hard Mode
He called it the Hard Mode.
(laughing)
If you search this up on YouTube,
you have to search the
Hard Mode, no space.
Otherwise you're not gonna find it.
Cause it's like that buried
within the search algorithm.
But the second animetuber
was this person called
Mr. Anime and he basically made his
anime YouTube channel to compete with Hard
'cause Hard was the only
anime YouTube channel around.
And then Mr. Anime was the second one.
And he really, at the time he really was
one of the big faces of anime YouTube.
And I say big, he had
like a 1,000 subscribers.
- That big shit back in the day.
- That is big shit back in 2006, 2007.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And then it was after
Mr.Anime that there were like
some other anime channels here and there
but those two are the
founding fathers of animetube.
We have them to thank for
where we are now basically.
- If people know the ending to the story
then you know how funny
that statement is know.
- I know right.
So then after a while I
made my YouTube channel
and I do my own thing.
And the very, very first shout out I got
was from a Mr.Anime
video and it's still up.
- It's video, is it?
- It's it's Mr.Anime.
- Wait, is his channel still up?
- Yeah, his channel is still up.
You can view his entire history
and everything that he did.
- Wow that's weird because
was that guy recently
got prosecuted for like
child pornography and they took
down his channel like that.
- Oh really?
- Yeah that Austin guy the singing guy...
Picture on screen.
Yeah I don't know.
They immediately took down his channel.
- I remember a couple
months ago a Mr.Anime video,
like popped up just randomly.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, so Mr. Anime,
the first time he shouted me out was just
he made a video.
I think it was called like
the face of Animetuber
or something and he
just shouted out a bunch
of OG anime reviews back in the day.
- What a nice was is that.
- So that was the very first
boost in subscribers I got.
I remember messaging him being like,
"Oh thanks a lot, man,
"dude like that they're
really helps me out.
"I got me like 300 subscribers."
Like, holy shit, that was
a lot back in that day.
I think that was the video that pushed me
over my first 1000 subscribers,
which was a big fucking deal.
So I was really happy and
I really respected the guy
as well because if not for him
I'd probably be less
confident to do what I did
like to start my YouTube channel
and especially no matter
what whenever you see
someone bigger than you shouting you out
that's that's like a big pat on the back.
I did well.
And he messaged me back being like,
"Nah, it's no problem, bro.
"I just really like your stuff congrats."
He couldn't even pronounce
my name back then.
I think in the video
he called me guy geek.
(laughing)
- Don't say that now there
are gonna call you guy geek.
- I've dug my own grave.
So that was the last kind of interaction
I had with him until-
- That was the first and last interaction?
- Yeah that was my first
and last interaction.
Back then the anime
YouTube community wasn't...
We knew we bought each other,
but we didn't talk to
each other that much.
- It was like the MSM days?
- Yes, so there wasn't an easy
way to talk to each other.
Apart from back when
YouTube had messaging.
Remember those days?
- YouTube DMs which were slowly just
phased out of existence, I guess.
And just nobody remembers that you could
DM people on YouTube,
but one day I just woke
up and I had this message
from this other anime
YouTuber who was called
ICO Ari soccer 420 who's also like-
- You remember that right.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Jesus Christ.
I know the entire
history of anime YouTube,
right here, right here.
- He asked me if I'd
heard about this article,
that's been like linked around.
And it was this article
that was this police report
that basically just said,
Trey Sesler has been arrested
for the murdering his family.
I'm like,
"Whoa, is this Trey Sesler, the anime man?
"The same Trey Sesler?"
(laughing)
- I am Trey Sesler.
- We got him first.
- I'm like...
Fuck I've just blanked
his actual name now.
All that's coming to mind is the anime-
- Mr.Anime.
Oh my God.
I can't believe I blanked
on the name mid-story.
- Why did you doubt me?
- Come on.
- I clicked on the article
and he had his face
and that was just the,
"Oh shit, is this real?"
I had like 50 different emotions.
- I kind of imagine how it feels.
- Just to see him because you don't know
how to react to this
because the more I read,
just the more sickening it got.
So the entire story was that apparently
Trey Sesler, Mr.Anime
had been playing around
with his brother and they
were playing around with guns-
- As they did in his channel.
- And they did.
See he had a lot of guns in
like his channel and everything,
but me back then I just think
Americans guns that's just what they do.
- That's what British people
think about Americans.
Unless you think Americans
just walk around and be like,
hey waving with guns.
- So he would just have
guns in his anime reviews
and I just thought that
was completely normal.
'Cause he was from Texas
as well and I was like
this is completely normal.
This is nothing to worry about.
- I thought there's a
text and watch the shooter
with that gun.
- Even now I see a texting with a gun.
I just think that's even normal.
Even after everything I've
just about to experience.
But I read the story and
he was playing around
with this guns with his brother
and apparently he
accidentally shot his brother
and he killed him.
And so the official story that he gave was
he didn't want his parents
to feel guilt or his family
to feel guilt about having their son
kill one of their brothers.
So apparently he just thought
might as well fucking
kill them all which is-
- It's a fucking awful thing.
- Which is a awful conclusion to come to.
So apparently he kills his entire family
and then it gets worse because
like the more information that comes out
the more we find out that he was actually
not only planning to kill
his family anyway but he was
actually planning a
Columbine-Style school shooting.
- Yeah, 'cause I saw like
this really good documentary
on YouTube I'm sure it's up there still.
- ReignBot, right?
- Yeah I think so.
It's basically covers the whole thing
but that's how I got all
my information as well
where he was planning
to do a school shooting
and did he post about it online
that he was going to do it
or something like that but basically
was on the way to the school
and that's when he got arrested.
- Yeah, yeah.
- 'Cause he was planning
the school shooting
for way before he's killed his family.
'Cause I think how he thought was
he killed his brother by accident,
but he was always planning
the school shooting anyway.
He had it all mapped out and everything.
So in between that he accidentally
killed his brother and killed his family.
And that's what outed him.
But he was always planning this
and there's this really ominous video.
I think it's the second
to last, Mr. Anime video
this on a channel that's just called
Mr. Anime is planning something.
I remember watching that thinking,
"He's taken a break from any Animetube."
- Or he's planning a new reveal.
- He's planing a comeback.
But I dunno 'cause he talks
about anime in that video.
So he might've been just
purely talking about anime
by I'm like with all the information
that we have now he's probably-
- That title was fucking scary.
- It's fucked, that title was fucked.
And the more information that came out,
the more I just didn't
know how to process this.
'Cause how would you process the fact that
one of the people you
looked up to and respected
just killed their family
and was planning to
shoot up a fucking school?
Like what what'd you do with that?
That bothered me for a while.
And I remember this was the
time I was at university
and people were like,
"Why does Garnt look like
"someone just died in
his family or something?"
- But I think the best
way I can describe it is
imagine if you like live in a small town
and you may be like you know
everyone in this small town
you might not be friends with
everyone in that small town
but you feel like this
small, tight knit community.
And then you find that
someone in this small
tiny community has done something awful.
It's like something that's
not like beyond words
beyond words, awful.
And then to try to process
this I made the video,
which is being recommended now.
- It's circulating everywhere.
- Even though it's eight years old
for some reason YouTube decided,
"Yeah people wanna see Garnt reacting to
Mr.Anime murdering his family."
I dunno how that came about.
- It's literally on
everyone's recommended,
it was on my recommended,
I think Connor was on it.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I don't know why it's
probably not monetize, right?
- No, no it's not monitized.
It just goes against everything
about the YouTube algorithms
like it's not monetized.
It's about a horrible tragedy.
It's about a very sensitive topic.
I mean it was eight years old.
- I think I uploaded this before even
like the monetization thing
like started on YouTube
or at least before I was monetized
'cause I had like a
1,000 plus subscribers.
So it wasn't massive.
I remember stumbling
upon a Mr. Anime video
even like way before I
knew about the whole like
anime YouTube hemisphere
and everything because
it was Mr. Anime review on Garnt
that made me wanna go watch Garnt.
(laughing)
- That guy has got a bright career.
- And I was like,
"Wow, this guy is like really fun."
He fucking had...
Do you know how ghetto his set up was?
He had like a webcam
or something to record.
And he was sitting on his bed
and he had his lap and
it was like a notepad,
almost like an Apple-
- An Apple notepad.
- An Apple notepad of the script.
And he was literally just
looking down at the Apple notepad
just reading off the script
and then every now and then I guess,
because he didn't know
how to edit these videos.
So instead he had a remote that controlled
the zoom of the lens.
He control the zoom with the lens
and just started talking to the camera
and then he just zoomed back out.
- Yeah, yeah, no cuts.
So he was like...
I remember in the Garnt
review he was talking about,
the acid scene in the Garnt
anime and how he was like,
"It made me go."
And then he stops and zooms in
and zooms really far into
his face and he goes,
"Fuck."
And then he zooms out with a dead face
and just goes back to reading it.
And that was the review.
No cots, no edits.
And I was like,
"Yeah I wanna watch this anime."
- Yeah, that was quality content
back in the day of animetube.
I remember when I started
coming out with my videos
I was one of the first to actually just
use an editing software,
even though it was just
putting images over
whatever I was say people were like,
"He's using windows movie maker?
"Impossible."
But yeah that's the story
of the first person I ever-
- Humble beginnings.
- Yeah.
- But I recommend like as
of a topic that is like,
I definitely recommend that
documentary on YouTube-
- It perfectly goes through
everything about it.
And at the end of the documentary,
I don't know how they got this footage,
but there's this-
- Oh the police footage?
- The police footage of
how he's like the jail cell
during the interview,
that shit is so scary man.
And to think,
"This is the guy who founded
"basically what I do for a living."
- I know right.
- Like that's so fucking scary.
- It's so weird 'cause
I've had this conversation
with a few people and we just think,
"There's a lot of shit
that's happened in 92."
That's right.
- I think there's stuff
that unfortunately happens
in every community that we
probably will never find out
some really fucked up shit
that people have done.
- Oh yeah I mean, we've only
recently out about a lot of it.
- It's really unfortunate
because we don't like to think
that we know people who are like that,
but at times proven anything that
I've met people who've
been friendly with people
who have done really
horrible stuff I'm sure.
- I never knew that one of my best friends
used to punch kids in the face.
- That's not bad, those
kids they punched me first.
I mean once you look up and respect
a fucking serial killer school shooter
then it's all downhill from there, right?
- Yeah, yeah exactly.
- I know hot it feels
to see a police pull me
and being like, oh no.
- It's just a mess of emotions.
First it's, surely this is fake.
- As you see it you're like,
"I've never seen a police report before."
- Yeah, could easily be doctored.
Like yeah, yeah.
- And then you're seeing all the counts
being slowly like added and you're like,
"Oh no, oh no, oh no this is bad."
- And I think that was the first time.
'Cause I had a conversation
with (indistinct) about
the anime review about how
we should process this.
And I remember him saying,
yeah, I think he just
he'll keep the memories
of Mr.Anime, like the same,
but it's just, he has to view
Mr. Anime and Trey Sesler
as like different people.
And I think that was the first
time I had just thought about
the entire process of having
to view online personalities
as different in-person as how they
portrayed themselves.
- It's like whole thing of like separating
the artists from the creation.
- Yeah yeah, exactly.
- And yeah, it was more the fact that
this happened in our
small community as well.
- Because it's like happening
in like the small rural town,
right when nothing happens.
- 'Cause I'm sure now in Animetube,
I'm sure there's some assholes somewhere.
- Someone doing some despicable shit.
- We don't know about but
they weren't a figurehead
in this very small community.
- They weren't the
fucking founding founder.
- The literal founding father.
- The more you say that out
loud the more I'm like, oh.
- The founding fathers tend
to normally be sketchy count.
- How do we sell that the
anime YouTube community
is like this really cool thing.
- Oh, the founding father
is a serial killer.
(laughing)
That's a conversation starter, isn't it?
- I like to think of it of...
It's one of those things that
was gonna be started anyway
eventually around that time.
Yeah it just so happened
that he was the first
or one of the first
Maybe that's the reason why nobody used
animate in the username until I came up
because I know for a fact
that some of my early videos,
man those comments were just like,
"The animate man, I thought
that guy went to jail?"
Like they legitimately
mistook me for Mr.Anime.
- Who would mistake you for that?
(laughing)
- Rewind that.
Flash back to five minutes ago.
- But like I obviously
didn't know about that news
until after I started my YouTube channel,
because I think what year
was it that he got arrested?
I mean, it was eight years ago I think...
The only reason I remember this is 'cause
the YouTube video that's been recommended
is eight years ago.
- So that's like 2012, right?
- Something like 2011, 2012.
- Was probably just a really bad time
because I started 2013 literally
right after it happened,
I didn't know about it until I started it
and I had like a decent
following and I was like,
"Oh fuck I can't go back now.
"I can't change my name now,
"I should have changed it."
- So what was like the early
years of animetube like?
So that was over like what,
well, how long you been here?
12 years did you say?
- Since 2007.
Okay, so how was the animetube
sphere from 2007 to 2012?
- It was like slow, right?
- It was very slow.
So before 2012, which I kind of like where
I think you came along, it
was the quality was not good
as it is, but it was fun.
I don't know I kind of in a way
I'm gonna sound so boomer saying this
but I kind of missed old YouTube where
kind of anything went-
- Always look profondly at the time,
when it was smaller, more manageable,
'cause he was more intimate.
- Yeah yeah, always look
back at that period,
especially on YouTube as well
I'm sure you all miss the
time when you may like 1000
you can just talk to random people.
It's so cool.
- I remember I made a video
when I hit a 1, 000 subscribers
and I thought I'd made it.
I thought-
- I thought.
"Mom, I'm dropping out of uni."
I swear, like, I've always
said this to people,
but the joy of hitting a 1,000 subscribers
is almost comparable to
hitting like a hundred thousand
or a million subscribers.
Because a 1,000 is just like whoa.
- A 1,000 is like monumental.
- It is, because it's a
number that is very easily
like quantifiable.
But it's also huge because thinking like,
"Wow there's a 1,000 people who like me."
Because once it gets to like a million
it starts to become something that
you just can't really
comprehend, like physically.
Whereas a 1,000 is like,
"Oh, shit I'm popular.
"I'm fucking popular.
- And back then it was
just as I grew into,
it was all about doing anime reviews
and a lot of people had different styles.
If you came in with an editing software
you were just...
I remember when like
Yazoo, Taku and Tristan
gloss reflection came along and they used
Sony Vegas to edit their videos
and it just fucking blew my mind.
- They used the paid pro.
- Some of the stuff they could get
away with that I couldn't
do using like putting images
on windows movie maker.
What the fuck?
- It was amazingly glorified PowerPoint.
(laughing)
- I think my favorite
animated video from back then
was this guy called Grumpy Jlisan.
- I fucking love him.
- I do not know.
- He's so good.
Yeah, he's an OG and he
doesn't make videos anymore.
But what he'd do is that
he'd do anime reviews
but he'd do it in like
the middle of a desert
in Arizona somewhere.
- You would review an anime while
like hiking through the desert.
- Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, so it was like,
he he was basically pre Casey
Neistat because what he'd do
he'd always start off his videos with like
with him walking towards the camera
in like the middle of the desert.
So what he would have to do is that
he would have to set up his camera,
hike like a hike away off screen
and then hike back into
view of the camera.
He wasn't like he was
hiking a short distance.
He wouldn't be literally like hiking over
hills and mountains sometimes
to get to the camera.
- How long was this intro?
Like two minutes?
- It was like super sped up
and you'd just see him
walking towards the camera.
So it'd be like a squirrel,
just like skirling like
towards the camera.
And he's like,
"Today, we're gonna talk about a bizarre."
- A lot of his reviews, he
always had like a place to go.
So he would start with
at the front of the trail
being like today we're gonna
talk about hunter, hunter
and then as he's walking, he
would talk about the show.
And then usually the one I saw,
I forgot which anime it was
but he was hiking up this mountain
and he must've like
perfectly timed this shit.
Like he must've done the hike beforehand
because the moment he got to the top
was when he finished his
conclusion on the show.
And he was just like,
"I've made it to the top guys.
"And that's the end of my review."
I'm like, that's fucking awesome.
- Thinking back it was very different
from what everyone was doing.
And we were just like,
"Oh, old man reviewing anime.
"That's pretty weird."
But thinking back, he was...
A lot of his ideas were really cool.
- Ahead of his time.
- A little bit ahead of his time.
- And that's why he stands out to me
apart from the guy who
killed himself, I guess.
No not killed himself
but killed someone else
but yeah it was kind of like
the wild West back then.
I mean all of you all.
So if that's the first era, we all like,
2007, 2012, what came after that?
What's like the era?
What years are we talking between?
'Cause I can't trust it.
'Cause I didn't start until 2015.
So all of it before that is like-
- I'd say around about...
I can't remember exactly
when it was founded,
but that was kind of like
the wild West of YouTube
where everyone was kind
of doing their own thing.
It was a mess of different things.
And then 2012 was kind
of what like where the
anime community really started to form
into this one one conglomerate.
And I think the big event that happened
was probably PodTaku.
- PodTaku was huge.
- It was the first time I
recognized anyone outside of you.
And I was like,
"Oh there's other people?
- And I remember because I was already...
So we had four original members.
There was Holden reviews,
Jean who was originally
called extra disturbed jeans
and a Tristan, the Glass Reflection.
And I remember what started
it was Tristan one day
messaged me out, messaged
me out of the blue
with the YouTube DMs being like,
"Hey do you wanna talk about
this new anime season?"
And this was before I'd
even started watching
seasonal anime.
This was before the concept of,
"Hey you can watch anime weekly
"and be hyped for seasonal anime."
- Because I'm pretty sure
you made a joke in one
of your videos where it's like,
why would I want to come
over the space of 12 weeks
where I could just come and warm?
That was a joke you made
and I remember that.
I thought you completely
forgot about that.
- That's an amazing joke.
- For some reason that stuck with me
and that's a great example.
I would like to come in one, go.
- And my thought process
is why would I want
a 12th of an orgasm when I can just have
one orgasm one second.
- Yeah and so we made this podcast,
which wasn't even a podcast.
It was kind of just a recorded Skype call
and we didn't know where to put it.
So I made the suggestion to put it
on YouTube because this was before
like it was an audio podcast.
It wasn't a visual podcast like this.
So nobody thought that's
putting audio podcasts
on YouTube at work.
And I was just like,
"Well, YouTube is so why not?
"Why not put it on YouTube?"
I don't like saying it like this.
'Cause it's kind of sounds like it's like
sucking my own dick or whatever,
but like PodTaku was a
big factor in shaping the
anime YouTube community of that time.
- No, absolutely.
- You get left as somebody
who wasn't even interested
in being anonymous
YouTube definitely shaped.
I think how I felt about it
because at the time I
was listening to PodTaku
like every week, like I never
wanted to be crossed my mind
but definitely when I got into it
I think a lot of the influences
came from listening to that.
So I think you may not
have shaped the generation
you were in but you definitely helped
shape the one that came after.
- There's a reason why even to this day
people who were around in the anime....
- People back then still are like,
"Yeah remember PodTaku?"
Even people who didn't
watch PodTaku, knew PodTaku
- I mean it's still a
big point in my life.
I think back to PodTaku very fondly,
even though it's like ended now
and I've moved on in my life.
It had a big part of
shaping me as a person.
And it's especially because PodTaku
was the first ever friends I made
that I could talk to anime with.
You know what I mean?
That goes all the way
back to the conversation
we had at the start about Holden and Jean
were literally the first people
I was able to bond over anime with.
And PodTaku was kind of
like my weekly, biweekly
kind of session where I could
just nerd over annually.
Just bring it into with your buddies.
And apparently a lot of
people looked up to us
back then because a lot
of people apparently
didn't also have friends
to watch anime with.
- I listened to it.
- And so that really...
I feel like that cemented the next era
of anime YouTube before
I think you came along
and I think that was kind of the era
of YouTube where it was, I think it was
it was a lost era where
people could just make content
without a monetary incentive in mind.
- Right, right, right.
- Because we did PodTaku not
because we were getting paid.
We weren't getting paid for it at all.
For a lot of it we basically made it
because we just wanted to...
It was a passion, but it
was kind of like this,
but back then this was before we had
any kind of monetization.
We were just four mates who would just go
go on a Skype call and record the audio
and just splice it together
and upload it on YouTube.
- And then I came in when
the fat checks start.
No, but like, I don't think
it's too much to say that,
this podcast included there's
a lot of anime podcasts now.
Big and small.
And I don't think it'd
be too far to say that,
PodTaku probably the one
who probably got the train
rolling in that side of attitudes.
- It kind of amazes me 'cause
like before this came along
before Trash Taste came along,
you look back to some of the
views and popularity of PodTaku
and it still basically
holds up almost to a lot
of the bigger podcasts that came after it.
I mean, there's only a few
podcasts that I can think
of that came after PodTaku-
- That anime related.
- Yeah, that we're able
to do better with it
in terms of using user stuff.
And PodTaku is like six years old now.
So that kind of blows my mind.
Do you wanna hear with
blast from the past?
- Sure.
- [Joey] Warning, the
following audio may contain
coarse language and other
materials that may not be suitable
for a younger audience.
Viewer discretion is advised.
- That is screaming to do it.
There's like maybe a couple of 100 people
watching this right
now who just cream that
that intro is like
ingrained in my mind, man.
Your accent warning.
It's like it's so 2012.
- [Joey] Also we may spoil
anything and everything.
So you have been warned.
- If you go to my channel,
the very very first
video is like a podcast.
It looks very reminiscent
of the editing style
of another podcast.
- Oh really?
- Looks very very similar
with the cubes flashing up between.
Oh yeah.
- Oh yeah.
- 'Cause yeah did you edit all of them?
- Oh, no so originally
it was basically between
me and Tristan and Holden who had to edit
most of the podcast.
And so we basically edited the audio
so they would sync up and we
would remove a lot of like
when you have calls on Skype.
- People talking over each other?
- People talking over each other
and you have this really
awkward pause where it's-
- You've cut it up smoother.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
And then we were like we wanted to make it
a bit more visual.
We couldn't just film
ourselves next to each other.
So we kind of just decided
to go with flashing boxes.
- Yeah it works really well.
- Yeah, yeah.
And that was our way of
just evolving the podcast.
And I remember after
PodTaku we kind of added
a few more people.
- I wanted to ask about
that because I was...
When I as a viewer, I was so confused.
There were just people
like towards the end
would you stop joining in?
And then I was like, J-Taku?
And I'm like what is
going on with all of this?
- Was Jimmy on the podcast?
- Yeah Jimmy was.
- It was so odd 'cause it just seemed like
people were just recycling
in and I was like,
"Wait, this is not what
I wanted the boys."
- For the big four.
- I wanted the big four back then.
As a viewer, I was so confused.
I don't think you guys like
ever explained any of that.
So, I mean, I'd be interested in that.
- For me it was because the
scheduling just got super hard
because like I said, we weren't
getting paid for anything.
So this was just us making time.
And we got to a point
with PodTaku where we were
having a fucking hard time keeping up with
this two week schedule.
So I wanted to and it had been
awhile since PodTaku started.
So I wanted to spice things up
and I wanted to see if there was like
we could get some chemistry
with other people.
And that's when I brought
on the idea of J-Taku
and adding more people and
making it a distinct brand
of PodTaku is where we
just talk about pure,
whatever we want to talk about.
It's kind of like a free flowing podcast.
And J-Taku is we're gonna
pick a specific topic
and we're gonna stay on top.
And that was the kind of idea of J-Taku.
It was kind of hit
everything 'cause it added
some new elements to the
podcast and also made it so
less of a load was on the
original four as well.
But yeah, it's interesting
to hear what you guys thought
about it as a view of it.
- 'Cause I didn't watch every single one
and then I think I just
saw like three J-Taku
and I was so confused and
then I watch it and I'm like,
"Who are half of these people?"
- And I think it really worked at first
because J-Taku did his job.
And then he got to the
point when J-Taku kind
Of even maybe became the flagship series.
'Cause if you look on even
look on the PodTaku channel
a lot of the most viewed videos ended
up being J-Taku, originally J-Taku videos.
Like our most viewed video was one where
we literally just talk about hental.
- Of course.
- But that was back when talking about him
and I was like very harsh.
Nobody likes nobody publicly
like 10 times Twitter
or anything like that.
- Allow me to introduce myself.
- But yeah.
So J-Taku kind of became
one of the flagship series
'cause he just got more views.
And the main, the original four people
it would just became harder
and harder us to schedule
with the original podcast.
And I think that's kind of what
brought like helps bring PodTaku to an end
because I feel like that era of anime tube
is defined by the start of
PodTaku and the end of PodTaku
because I think the end of PodTaku really
it coincidentally coincided
with a lot of times when
Joey really rose and people realized
they could do anime
content for money as well.
Which just wasn't an idea before then.
And I remember, I mean,
should I talk about the end of PodTaku?
- Go ahead.
- If you want man.
- Are we about to do this now?
Am I really going to bring this up.
- It's up to you.
- Okay so I guess I've
never talked about this
but we've obviously
gotten a lot of comments
about PodTaku on this point on caps.
Comment on this podcast and it was weird.
I don't think anyone's really
publicly talked about it
and to preface this I still
love everyone on the podcast.
I'm not about to talk mad
or anything like that.
I don't belong in the story
the long and the short
of it is that we came into
some creative differences
about which way the podcast could go.
Because to me PodTaku
was the defining podcast
of the anime community as I have just said
and I really wanted to push that further.
I wanted to go talk to like evolve more
'cause I saw the potential in
how big the podcast could be
because the problem was that
we had trouble keeping up
with our schedule and then we
took like a seven month break
or something like that.
- It's very long.
- It was a very long.
Yeah, yeah, Yeah.
And the reason for that was basically
the podcast didn't really
have like a designated leader
leading it.
So I'm thinking like at the
beginning of the podcast
it was mainly me and Tristan
who were getting things
like getting things done.
I mean Jean, loved Jean
she was like the mother
of the group, but she
was like she would like
come in and out because she was very busy
with her real life.
Holden fucking times busy.
I know I've talked just told him before,
unless you tell...
If you tell Holden to do
something, he'll fucking do it.
- If you don't he won't do it.
- If you don't, he's not the type of...
He wasn't the type of person
that would like push people to do it.
And I think he's changed
now for the better.
And I think PodTaku was definitely
a big learning experience for him as well.
So I think he's definitely
grown as a person,
but back then it was mainly me and Tristan
who was pushing stuff to
get done on the podcast.
And Tristan started to
get less and less involved
because he started to
transition doing anime reviews
as a hobby to actually
finally getting paid for it.
Cause he had opened his patreon.
He was the only one that
was actively doing videos-
- There was time when Tristan was like
really at his peak,
he was not really growing up at that time.
- I remember his patron was a big deal.
- Yeah, exactly.
Because he was the only one
who had other commitments
for his own YouTube channel.
So he just had less time than all of us.
And then for me, that was also the time
when I got my job at BBC.
So you see all these
factors coming into play
where the driving force of the podcasts
just had less time to really make episodes
and people in J-Taku we
were all good friends,
but they weren't the original four.
They didn't really have the,
I'd say authority to really takeover.
- You can't really step in and be like,
"This is mine."
- Yeah exactly.
So we basically took a seven month hiatus
or it's a hiatus but it
was more of not nothing
was getting done.
- Yeah I won't send
anything in the group chat.
- Nothing was really happening.
- They left you on read.
- And it was basically because
we just didn't have the time.
And what was the driving force
for it to be revamped was
that was the point when I
wanted to return to YouTube.
I was getting bored with
my job and I was like,
"Okay, first step I wanna
put all my hard work
into PodTaku."
And really revamping this because
Tristan's doing really well
with whatever he's doing
with his patron.
And I saw potential for
not only me coming back
but also pushing PodTaku
into something even bigger
and better than what it was
with help formally and
trying to monetize it.
And they just basically making it-
- Have an incentive ever
to turn up every week.
- Exactly, exactly.
And so it ended up being...
I was the big driving
force to getting PodTaku
back on its feet.
And that's why I got
super, super invested in it
because I was the one who was getting
trying to get episodes done.
I was editing a lot of them
not because I wanted
to be paid or anything
but I just wanted this-
- It was your passion.
- I wanted my passion to
be back on the ground.
And as soon as I felt it
was kind of getting back
off the ground, I remember
Trisan coming to me
and he was like,
"I want it to end."
You know what I mean?
And I looking back now
I totally understand
why he did, right because this is where,
this is where I put it back to
creative differences because
he saw that we weren't
getting as many views as we
used to before the hiatus.
And also the dynamic of the
group was very different
than when then when we started some people
weren't getting along as well
as they were at the beginning.
So he wanted PodTaku to just end there.
He wanted to be like,
"Okay, instead of just
fizzling, fizzling out,
I wanted to end here.
And I really really tried
to convince him to be like,
"Look I know we're going
through some very big issues now
"but I see potential in this."
There was a lot of factors that I saw
that could potentially have
driven a lot of hype back
in PodTaku before we ended there.
We had Jean had just left.
But she was gonna come
back we had scheduled that
we had also scheduled PodTaku two episode
which was like our most popular one.
So I was like,
"Look, we can do the come."
I really, really tried to convince him
that it was too early
because I totally agree
with all the problems
that the podcast had in order to survive
and to go further we
would have had to make
a lot of big changes and
they could have very easily
blown up in our face.
- I guess it's one of those
things where it's like
you could try, but you
could very easily fail.
It's one of those things
where you're like,
"Do I wanna put in this work
"and I can get the guaranteed paycheck?"
I kind of get it but at
the same time, I'm like
"As a viewer I knew how big
it could have been as well."
Looking at my position now.
And I understand how it all works.
Like, yeah, it could have been an option.
It could have been severed, definitely
- It would have needed a lot of work
and it would have taken a big risk
and we could have failed massively.
But for me as a person, I
would rather give that a go
then the wonder.
And it got to the point
when it was just like
it was just this one clash, right of just,
I thought he was too early to end it
and Tristan wanted to want it to end it.
And it was unfortunate
that I signed, fortunately
I didn't get my way.
(laughing)
They didn't listen to me.
I tried so hard.
- There's a video that you
guys all made when it ended.
And I remember watching this and that one
of those moments, you're
like, please say science
please say science.
But I remember watching
that video and it like...
'Cause I remember the order,
it was like you first.
And it was like, Tristan was last.
And I love trust and by
the way, just say it.
But I remember watching him, I seem like,
man it kind of seems like
everyone was like really
wanting to keep doing this,
but then Tristan didn't,
almost as a viewer.
It wasn't like that.
It was at the end-
- As a viewer I think that's an impression
I could be totally wrong just compression.
- I mean, that was definitely a fraction
that supported my stance.
There was the faction that
support a Tristan stance.
- As someone who creates
now I can understand both.
I don't care about either.
You know what I mean?
- I mean it's definitely
a tough decision right.
Anybody in that position
would have been like,
"Fuck do I take the risk or not?"
- If his heart's not in
it, his heart's not in it.
If you're gonna like drag someone along
who doesn't wanna do it, you can't like.
- So was there no option to
just do it without Tristan?
- I mean, we wanted to
respect Tristan's wishes.
There was the conversation of like
should we do this without Tristan?
But it just felt wrong.
- Yeah understandable.
- Because I wanted to leave the option.
I asked Tristan, would it
be okay if we continued
and then at any point,
if for whatever reason
you want to return the
doors they were always open.
And Tristan was like adamant,
"No, I don't."
And I understand because
this was his baby.
I'm like, I don't feel
comfortable letting my baby go
and just seeing what happens.
So that's was kind of like the last straw,
there was no going back from that.
And yeah, that's basically how it ended.
And it was after that I kind
of lost a lot of motivation
because I'd put so much of
myself into getting this revamped
and it just felt like it
was just all taken away
and it was out of my control
and I learned a lot from
PodTaku with like learning
working on group projects
and everything like that.
And I wanna say I'm not throwing
shade at Tristan at all.
We still get along great.
I love Tristan.
It was just a point where we just had
creative differences-
- And it happens.
- I feel that's a very normal thing.
What I'm trying to say is I've really-
- Demonized and like don't.
- Yeah I'm not demonizing Tristan.
We just had a different
way of approaching things.
I still think back to
PodTaku and I still think,
"Hey, I think it ended too early."
And he obviously thinks the other way
and he thought the other way back then
and that's basically what it ended to.
- How it is, man.
- That's how it is.
- Yeah obviously we
don't want anyone going
and being like,
"Who the fuck man?
"Why don't you not believe in it, man?"
I mean, like I said earlier,
like if your heart's on it
and your heart's not in it.
That's not gonna happen.
- I mean, can anyone
like really blame Tristan
again, it's a fucking...
I would've really vibrating as well.
- If I didn't believe in it
I'm normally someone who's like
adamant about shit, right.
So I would be like,
"No, no, I don't believe in this."
Like I would do like that.
- Yeah, exactly.
So it's just how it is, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah I always look back
to think what could it be?
But that was just the end of an era.
And now we're in a new era
and everyone's gone down
the different paths.
I'm really amazed to see
what people are getting
onto nowadays.
And it's fucking great.
And I still speak to all the cast members
every now and again especially
when we would get to
meet in a convention.
- Hey, bottom line is
that at least there isn't
a single member of PodTaku
that went and killed their family.
(laughing)
They didn't go down to Mr.Anime.
That's the silver lining.
- 80s outro where it tells
you what we've opened up to.
- The fucking snapshot is like yeah.
- Joey, didn't his family.
- Oh my God.
- Okay, okay.
Before we end it, right
I guess the way I see it.
Is if you were still doing
PodTaku your Trash Taste
probably wouldn't exist.
- Yes that's true.
- That's what I'm saying.
I'm not trying to say
I'm glad that you'll pass your project,
but I'm glad that we have this.
- No, I'm very glad as well.
Please don't kill your families.
(laughing)
Just going to throw that out there.
- You're not British, how do I get a gun?
I don't even know how do you do that?
- I don't wanna have
to make a twit longer.
That's like, so about Connor-
- My thoughts on Seadog V God.
(laughing)
- This has gotta be real.
I wanna kill your family, Joey.
Just stop talking about killing.
I'm so sorry.
- Until you choose with
anime, let's fucking do that.
- I miss her anime I mean the army man.
I mean both.
Yeah we should've seen
the signs all along.
It was in the name.
- My God it kind of felt
that when PodTaku ended
that it kind of like,
it's like tearing down
the Berlin wall, right?
- Yeah.
- Just letting everyone fucking loose.
'Cause I feel like when a
big pillar in a community
kind of falls right it's
just like a ton of people
covering for all right.
Basically like it's kind of
like everyone's looking for
the new, like, all right who's the person
I'm gonna listen to.
We don't really have that at the moment.
I don't feel.
And I think we do, we
have a few big people
but I feel that that's when definitely,
like you said the new era
just was like all right.
- Because back then it was
all about doing anime reviews.
And then I would say the
content started to really like
it kind of like opened the doors
to all different kinds of content.
Like you were doing more blogging videos
and analytical channels
start to come along.
So I feel, it was a
coincidence that it happened
during the end of PodTaku
but I feel like for our community,
that was a big turning point.
- Oh definitely.
Yeah, absolutely.
- Because I remember that was when
demo came along as well,
near enough back then when
he was starting he
changed the game as well.
- No, definitely like there is...
I don't think there's a single attitude
that's on the platform right now
and no longer on the platform
who didn't look up the
demo in any accident.
- He did anime stuff.
- Yeah anime stuff like demo
was just a name that came back.
He's like the dad that
went to go buy cigarettes
and just never came back.
- I'm glad I came into it when I did.
I feel like I came into
it at the time where
it's perfect because it was where
I wanted to make the
content I wanted to make.
- I think you came at a perfect time
because it was around the time
when the whole anime
YouTubing thing really
diversified itself in
terms of its content.
So people like you who did very
unconventional anime content,
it was very to just slip in.
- It's great I'm glad that
it's gone to the point where
we can make a set like this.
'Cause in my mind, I
didn't wanna do a podcast
unless it was this good.
Like I have no interest in it.
Like I don't wanna do
audio, an audio podcast.
- This is what I kind of
wanted to push PodTaku
to the direction of going like me.
Like we obviously didn't
live in the same place
but my idea was,
"Hey, what if we all flew to a place
"record tons of episodes and
released it on a schedule?"
And we could do that on
a periodic basis based
on like, whatever funding
we could've gotten.
But I'm glad that I
have you guys now who...
It's taken me how long?
- I'm not the one saying that.
People in that first episode were like,
"This is just PodTaku 2.0?"
No, I'm hosting next.
I'm just gonna do that intro.
You have to do it.
You have to do it now.
- I mean, it's, it's great, man.
I mean, I like you said earlier
about the ambition of it
I think us three really
have like really great ideas
of ways that we want to
make this not just a podcast
but something really crazy.
Like they like the Akihabara video.
It was just like just a
step in the Stephanopoulos.
- I like to say, I thought
of the Akihabara video
in the shower.
- Thank you to supporting this episode.
- You guys are freaking awesome.
If you'd like your name
on the screen just search
on other bonuses, then make
sure to aside from patreons.
- start taking more showers
It's super Zen.
- You know what you can start doing
following us on Twitter and the sub Reddit
which is always in the description below,
send us your meme, send us your giga game,
the showers anime.
- One of us will make a
post and the other two
you have to figure out who did it.
(laughing)
- What the fuck tier list, I was like,
"Wow, it's poking for the hip."
And he was like,
"I don't know who did it."
- In my head I was like,
"Who the fuck is this?'
- I signed up to make a tier
list account just for that.
I've made one of my life.
- I love the commitment.
- That was good for the memes, man.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Yeah but if you'd like
to send us your memes
then the Twitter and
sub Reddit always open.
You guys send us some fucking
dank memes over there.
- I love the chess monga.
- Because I'm way too much
town to be making this up.
Some of you too good to go.
- Yeah hope you guys enjoyed this episode
and we'll see you guys in the next one.
- The Neanderthal boys,
no the viewers are the
naughty Neanderthals.
- Were the animetubers who
haven't killed their fam.
- There is no way we are
getting monetized this episode.
- Worth it for the joke.
- I've been your host, Joey,
and as always my co-host Garnt and Connor.
And we'll see you guys next episode.
- Share to my YouTube.
(laughing)
(upbeat music)